at the End of
[Music]
Time 13
O well hello everybody it's Wednesday
and here we are once again yeah Tom is
very excited about this topic I think
he's going to have all kind of [__] to
say I know most I know most of the cases
that yeah I gave him like a list of
because I just went through and picked
ones that I thought were the most
interesting like out of all the lists
that I found of famous military mishaps
yeah and they're not all American yeah I
was going to stick to All American but
then some of them I was like man this
one's too good I don't want to leave
this one off you know what I mean so
yeah so they're mostly American but
there's some like from a couple other
countries too just because I thought
they were amusing so like I said um I
tried to kind of keep I wanted the show
to be like entertaining now some of the
some of the mishaps people did die all
right uh so I'm not going to say that
but I wanted the circumstances of them
to be like kind of ridiculous so that
even though people died which is not
funny like still the circumstances were
still kind of funny just because they
were absurd you know what I mean so
that's kind of the the thing that I use
so I gave Tom like a rundown of the list
of one of the ones and if you know of
any other ones like I said that you
could you can jump in on it yeah if we
have time at the end there's a couple I
remember I remember yeah or if I say
something that jogs your memory you know
what I mean then you can jump in so
that's totally fine um I'm not super
worried about it I have like a long list
but it's not you know excessively long
because you know how I do yeah I've
learned to kind of cut stuff down
because I tend to bite off more than I
can chew I'm just like oh this is a G oh
that's a good one too and then like I
have five hours worth of material
everybody's showing in all the all the
regulars are showing up well hi
everybody what's going on yeah Wednesday
night hopefully you guys are having a
good 2024 so far but um yeah do do you
want to like update on what is happening
yeah first thing I uh is that my dad's
back in the hospital yeah um the entire
Mississippi [__] Clan and I mean in
the Scottish sense of the [__] not
with a K you guys don't be it's all
convered
all right but my my aunt's the first one
on there on there he's in the
hospital um fighting a lot of stuff long
cancer but they actually got that under
control uh his heart you know he had
that quadruple bypass already with the
turkey neck sure yeah uh he's got some
congestion going on in there and he's
got pneumonia he's an
ICU uh but I haven't heard word back
from my aunt my a Chris is going to be
showing up
uh tonight over there and I'll get a
more detailed account I he wasn't he
didn't want to talk over over the phone
yeah cuz Tom kept calling him yeah I
call him and in past couple days he call
there's no answer so it could be that
he's not he can't hear it cuz his hear
he doesn't have his hearing aid he I
didn't know he needed a hearing aid but
he needs a hearing it well so we're just
going to see whether or not how bad it
is I may have to leave the show which
gone for a little while little while
just so so he can go out there and see
what's going on yeah like before when
his dad had bypassed and he was gone for
two weeks and now if he rejoins the
Nether world of the
force um we had to go through uh my aunt
is the executive of his will and so I'm
going to get
stuff cuz you're his only son yes yeah
his only child yeah but the thing is
that the house doesn't go to me it goes
to his sister yeah so she's going to get
the
house um but I think I'm getting his
truck and a bunch of other [__] and I
don't know how I'd get it back here
right um I know uh I know that
uh my cousin's going to get a lot of his
stuff too because that's like his dad
also you look at you look at my dad me
my dad and my cousin my he's he's also
he's a Navy vet but he served with the
101st Airborne Division which is the
weirdest thing he had both Navy and army
medals served in the
Infantry um if you look at us all if
we're about the same age he actually
looks more like my dad than I
do this just funny that's interesting
isn't it yeah he looks more like my dad
that I do but uh so you know they were
pretty close too but uh he's going to
get stuff too probably a bunch of guns I
might get some guns we'll see they're
not really the kind of guns I'm into
he's into the [__] bolt action
super Precision [__] bunch of reloading
gear I don't know how I get it all back
here and I know he's got a huge gun safe
that I don't think that' go back of that
truck that that thing must weigh tons
but uh probably we'll just see it would
take a while to get through that yeah I
wanted to say too that uh Tammy just
said my mom died yesterday oh yeah going
to have to drive to Pennsylvania on
Sunday to clean out the apartment uh
she's been bat off with COPD for a long
time I'm really sorry hear that that's
awful we were watching The
Frighteners yeah and in that one episode
when when damers when when when's
character yeah it started to scare me
when damers was talking about that it
was just uh when he it was rspk and it
was uh [__] uh just your subconscious
going around killing people that scared
me and the [__] the um the smoke
alarm smoke alarm went off and then it
stopped on its own It beeped the one in
our bedroom beeped and then the one out
in the hall beep the one in our bedroom
beep twice and then the one in the
hallway beeped once yeah and we but it
didn't beep anymore yeah and that we had
changed that battery just a couple weeks
ago couple weeks ago yeah cuz that makes
it different makes like a chirping noise
you know you guys know no it went off
like it was like it was yeah like there
was
smoke so it didn't do it again then the
next day I was s sitting in bed it was
around the same time and it did it
together it only chirped three or four
times yeah like it
and I was worried about that I I was
worried about it at night too I thought
it would do it again and like scare the
[__] out of us in the middle of the
night and wake us up because it's so
loud it's been over a week now it hasn't
made any any noise although now that
we're talking about it it'll probably
yeah it might go up but on those days
that was the day that was the day
unbeknown to me that my dad was going to
the
hospital and we thought too because you
had woken up a couple times and you
couldn't bre I couldn't breathe yeah
like cuz you kept getting up and she
like man I feel like I can't breathe and
stuff like that so you might have been
like you might have been like
sympathetic yeah cuz that's what he said
he says I can't breathe because he
didn't know you you didn't know until
after so we were thinking in hindsight
that might have been what that you're
right I didn't know what was what why I
thought it was just because of the
movie yeah but yeah maybe that's what it
is there's a bunch of stuff happening at
once the movie and that so I was having
weird premonitions of it I guess
sympathetic signals of it yeah like you
knew something was wrong yeah that's
pretty common I kept waking up like I
couldn't breathe and that was yeah like
a bunch of times times for about 3 or 4
days before the alarm went off before he
went in so it must have been bothering
him for several
days or a couple
weeks how long was I doing that two
weeks maybe off and on yeah maybe yeah
something like that I'd wake up in the
middle of night felt like I couldn't
breathe yeah I'd have to get up and walk
around and I was like there's nothing
wrong with you I was like are you having
a panic attack or I wasn't really sure I
was like but you're not really stressed
out I can inhale easily and exhale there
was no problem but felt like I couldn't
breathe and I felt like I wanted to
hyperventilate for I've never had it
happen before it's weird so maybe that's
what it is but yeah so Tom's um he's
keeping in communication with his aunt
yeah on Facebook um and she's go getting
to Mississippi tonight she's there
already she's there already yeah so
they're going to like assess and so
serious it is yeah right so they're
going to if they say it's like super
serious then fly out then Tom will have
to fly out probably this over the next
couple days we don't know how long he's
going to be there but we like I said it
was like last time where he went this
was a couple years back where your dad
had a bypass it was two weeks yeah you
ended up being gone two weeks yeah but
it won't be that if he dies he dies
it'll only be a few
days yeah we'll see how it goes so we're
not really sure right and another thing
that happened today was that a job
interview that I did two months ago yeah
they called me back today and said do
you want the job sorry it took so long
yeah but we've been like restructuring
blahy blah it's an excellent job yeah
it's it's a commute um it's around here
it's in
leeburg um but it's not as far as you
know cuz I was working at Daytona before
that's an hour [__] drive this place
is more like a half hour so it's like
you something like that it's right it's
actually not too far you know the
Chinese buffet we go to on the weekends
it's like a it's like four or five miles
farther than that you know mean so it's
out there it's a gamechanging amount
well they it's not six figures but man
it's well when I first interviewed for
it like the money was okay but it was
about the same as what I was making in
Daytona which is not great but okay but
like he said um yeah well we're offering
you like I'm not going to say how much
it is but like this amount and I was
like cuz I was sitting there thinking
man I don't want to have to commute but
then he said that and I was just kind of
like oh never mind okay yeah it was
twice I'll do that it was yeah it was
like almost it was it was a lot more
than they had offered off initially yeah
um which is twice twice as much as the
best one she's had and I will be their
only designer yeah her own office and
everything huh aren't they building yeah
eventually they are yes they are
building me an office like in their new
office so what that means is is it's
going to impact the production there
some shows some things will slow down
yeah we'll still we're we'll still going
to do the streams in the evenings like
Monday night Wednesday night Friday
night like we normally would because I
would just work normal full-time hours
um but I might not be able to do the
streams like by myself like the week but
I will try to do like at least one like
maybe on Sunday or something like that
like a book review or a movie review cuz
I really like doing those so but I I
should still be able to do them like on
the weekends we're still going to do
some side projects I mean you know we
always do side projects we might do the
stream a thing every once in blue once
in a blue moon we'll see we're going to
make videos still so it it'll all it's
just we we have to find the new Elite
equilibrium because you know me and Jen
both are on physical training schedules
working out and [__] [__]
so we have to make sure that we have
enough time for everything yeah but uh
but the thing about it is like you know
the guy called and he was just kind of
like um you know offer me a lot more
money than initially and you know I
frankly I need a new car um buy a car I
need to pay down some credit card debt
you know what I mean um we need to buy
some furniture so uh because we don't
really have that much so I was just kind
of like any more artwork yeah so I so I
told Tom I was like do you think I
should take it he's like [__] yeah take
it and I was like yeah that's what I was
thinking yeah cuz you and she doesn't
lose any of her independent clients or
anything and there's another kind of
part-time remote job that's like a major
client like a freelance yeah Freel yeah
that if that comes through which did you
hear back no okay well we'll see it
doesn't really matter now yeah but um
but yeah she was offering that was like
I said that was a remote job that was
also designed um that would be another
two grand something like $1,500 a month
yeah just for like a side gig just for a
side gig yeah so so I don't know if I'm
going to get that or not I mean she did
say that it's like yeah would you do it
but um you know I haven't she was going
on maternity leave at the end of the
week and stuff like that so I don't know
if that's going to go through or not
that would help out around here and
because I'm doing the damn new uh
landscaping and everything I built a
damn
Mountain a dirt Mountain they they
delivered a whole truckload of dirt yeah
they came from Lowe's yesterday yeah and
so made a dirt Mountain he's doing the
whole Landscaping in the it's going to
look it's going to look [__] fine I'm
going to show youall a photo when it's
done it's probably going to be a while
but we'll see kind of up the value of
this house we already made money on it
yeah which is good yeah it's gone it's
appreciated by 30 Grand in a year yeah
cuz we haven't really lived here that
long no we've only been 18 months well
the and and when we first moved in we
were renting it and then like the owners
were just kind of like hey you want to
buy it like several months after we
rented it for several months and they
finally like we finally got that [__]
together and did no I didn't they didn't
ask me if I wanted to buy it I knew they
wanted to sell it yeah yeah I knew they
wanted to get rid of it and after we
were here for a few months I just said
look I'm going to buy the house yeah
yeah I went I went to our special Latin
underground [__] real estate
place and uh it was the same real
realators that they use they got me
approved for all this
[__] yeah is good yeah like I said you
have good credit you can get VA stuff
and like that that's the secret to being
a white boy is knowing how to use the
banking and the credit system that's a
special skill yeah that's a special
skill that we have know how to use them
damn Banks you got to do it
yeah yeah um Tammy's talking about her
mom said yeah she'd been sick a long
time said uh yeah she had smoked a long
time too yeah so if you can make those
changes do it that was her problem she
never stop stopped smoking barely moved
out of her recliner yep that's the same
my dad my dad was basically sedentary
lifestyle smoking with a [__] old
school Southern diet he grew up with
sucking on a baby on a Down Baby Bottle
f with milk and pork grease in it that's
back in the [__] 40s that's pretty
much early 50s that's that was the way
they were back then and
he drinking that bacon grease and you
know he ate he ate good and he had
diabetes so lot most of his teeth fell
out my grandfather also had diabetes
yeah and he was he's a short guy and my
dad also has diabetes he's a short guy
like me but that he just got ravaged by
by um diabetes [__] He's skeleton you
know he's skinny although my dad's isn't
that bad but yeah my dad's real [__]
skinny my grandfather had it he didn't
die of it but and after the chemo they
say he's just very frail I said I
wouldn't recognize him I'm kind of
dreading to go to go there and see him I
don't want to remember him like that
yeah that really oh that sucks that b
yeah he just said he's just a cuz I
remember like when you went to see him
when he had the bypass and that was what
two three years ago right that was when
we were at the old house still so that
must have been 3 years ago at least and
he's still trucking but um but I
remember you were real upset when you
got back yeah that was when you started
like working out and like taking test
and all that kind of stuff cuz you're
like I don't want to up like that well
see I saw you seen it I saw him go
through all that [__] in every bit of
that [__] was avoidable but he didn't
just another generation you know what I
mean yeah they didn't really think think
like like that yeah everything all that
[__] could have been avoided with diet
and proper preventative maintenance and
[__] um he never would have had that
diabetes if he didn't grow up on a
southern diet from a just heavy pack
with sugar you know yeah I mean and it's
just it's not the best for you yeah you
can have it every now and then but don't
eat like that all the time yeah they
that's going to [__] up that's going to
[__] you up your system isn't meant to
produce that much in not be able if you
eat a bunch of sugar your system has to
prod produce a [__] ton of insulin to
try to [__] neutralize all that Sugar
you didn't EV we didn't evolve in in in
an environment where it had all these
processed [__] carbohydrates yeah so
the bodies have a hard time deal yeah
they can't keep up with it you got to
eat you got to eat a heavy protein and
vegetable diet meat and
vegetables you want to stay away from
bread and potatoes and like I said you
can't eat that stuff but just keep it to
keep it got to keep it kind of low every
time we go to like if we go to the all
you can eat buffet all I eat is meat and
vegetables yeah mostly fish yeah fish
shrimp broccoli yeah that's about no
noodles no rice no nothing
African-Americans the same problem
because they basically eat kind of a
southern diet they just [__] eat High
[__] carbs a lot of these black isms
are actually Southern isms and they
[__] have bad diabetes and [__]
yeah but it's white people too if
they're from the Deep South they have
bad diabetes yeah I mean we well I
growing up like my you know grandparents
and stuff like that yeah were like
Tennessee mhm and the stuff they would
eat was just so so bad for you it tasted
great though it does taste good yeah you
know it does food is a religion for
people in the Deep South it's just
Southerners in general it's a [__]
religion but everything has to be just
like completely soaked in fat and yeah
and sugar real sweet sweet that's
[__] it's like one it's like it's
like a syrup it's almost like syrup
[__] it's too it's too sweet for me and
I love stuff and we [__] love soda I
drink a [__] two liter of [__] see
I never got into soda [__] love it I
like soda and it got worse when they put
that
[__] corn syrup as a sweetener in
there it was better if it was just sugar
just sugar yeah oh like if you want just
sugar get
throwback the throwback is a lot better
for you than than uh it kind of tastes
better too I it is yeah if you can't
find [__] throwback go to a Mexican
store and get Mexican Coca-Cola Mexican
it's much better it tastes much better I
think even though I'm not a conosur cuz
I don't really like like I said if I'm
going to drink a cola or like a soda
it's going to be like ginger ale or
Sprite or something Mexican soda root
beer I like root beer Mexican soda is
all cany sugar I drink water all day
every day water and coffee that's all I
ever drink your body and booze your body
can can break down cane sugar a lot
easier than that damn corn syrup what's
it called hydrogenated corn syrup What's
that name of that [__] what's the full
name of I forgot just some kind of I
can'ta took all that corn and tried to
turn it into a sugar substitute it's
cheap but it's [__] terrible for you
well that's what they use to put weight
on cows like that they slaughter for
steaks and whatnot yeah
yeah yeah um Ian England said my uncle
Royce was a deep south boy he had
diabetes bad it seemed like every time
we went to see him he was missing
another body part yep cutting off legs
and [__] lack of circulation teeth
falling out uh my grandmother they cut
her both of her legs off eventually from
the knee down and it's just because of
what they it's no joke man the southern
TI will [__] no joke they'll take
your [__] body parts off and and in
the media in the old media they would
also [__] warn uh African-Americans
that you know hey man diabetes in the
African-American population is real
[__] high It Go but they didn't say
anything about white people because they
just generically put all white people in
the same bucket what was tearing up
[__] black people was tearing up
white people in the Deep South too
because they ate the same thing
basically [__] it's just that there were
most white people aren't from the Deep
Cell like I said Mississippi Alabama I'm
kind of thing it's like you can you can
eat what you want within with moderation
like if you want to pig out one day um
you know every few weeks or once a month
or something like that like on somebody
I'm going to go to Waffle House and get
on you know what I mean I don't you know
what I'm saying but it's like I want to
eat this big big huge thing you can do
that it's not going to kill you but you
can't eat like that every day like all
day every day which is what a lot of
Southerners did back then feeding
[__] grits every day yeah they would
get up and they'd have this massive
breakfast with like bacon and grits
bacon grease in the and [__] yeah
like a whole like eggs and I mean eggs
are good for you but I mean you know
what I mean real coarse cornbread yeah
all that [__] is fcking and then a
couple hours later they eat this big
[__] lunch and then just you know
everything was just glasses and glasses
of sweet tea which is [__] got a [__]
ton of I can't even imagine how many
calories that is yeah sweet tea is more
syrupy and sugary than
soda I saw a Brit some British guys do a
[__] review they went into a Southern
Restaurant down in the Deep South and
they had sweet tea and they they [__]
loved it they go yeah that's just
[__] it's good that shit's addictive
man but if you grow up on that [__] it
kills you you can't drink it all the
time yeah they were like that is so
sweet I go yeah like I said just save it
save it for a treat if you really like
it in a glass that big with ice in it
and everything the sweet tea in there
there's probably about one3 a cup of
sugar in it that's how much sugar is in
it which like I said how many calories
is that a lot yeah and I think that
people don't even realize because it's a
drink so you don't really think it's
like oh this has like 400 calories in it
but it might there no lemon in it it's
just all sugar which yeah like I said
it's good but you can't drink that every
day you'll die yeah yeah Zan said
intermittent fasting is what I do also
just eating small portions yeah it's
better to eat a lot of small portions
than a couple of big huge ones although
I guess it depends on the person because
everyone's um metabolism is different I
cheat I must tell you in your late 30s
start taking testosterone if you're a
man women you can bolster a little bit
of therapeutic nandrolone it's anything
to keep your mitochondria and your
mitochondria and your cells [__]
producing moving your metabolism along
cuz part of it is that you get old so
you start shutting down and everything
you eat you can't you can't burn it or
process it just goes on as fat and it
builds up in your [__] arteries and
you die man I'm [__] 54 I got [__]
pipes instead of veins going out they're
going up my legs and everything I don't
have to worry about [__] clogging in
my arteries my arteries are [__]
three times the diameter of a normal
person's arteries he's got big ass
arteries Fu I could Supply blood to
another person you can put another
person there and I just he's like here
have some of my blood have some of my
super Tom blood yeah I read up on all
that [__] and I didn't believe in any of
that damn corporate propaganda who's
trying to sell you patented medicine no
all natural [__] synthetic [__]
testosterone and
hormones [__] that you stop making when
you get older just replace it hormone
replacement that's what it's called your
teeth fall out you put in new teeth
falls teeth hormones fall out put in
false hormones you'll [__] feel a lot
better she people thought about it that
way maybe they wouldn't be so yeah
that's all it is cuz it's it doesn't we
me out yeah Zan also said most Americans
eat until they aren't hungry anymore and
that's not how you should eat that's
over eating yeah you should really stop
fighting over it you should always stop
before you're full because look I I
can't overeat literally because if I do
overeat then I will throw up a lot of
people showing up yeah me and Jen go to
the damn ichy Bon all you can can eat
Chinese buffet is [__] great but you
can eat a clean meal there man I'll eat
a [__] a pound of damn boiled shrimp
and go eat nothing but chicken roasted
chicken if you pick through it there's a
lot of healthy stuff on there don't stay
away from the rice and the pasta yeah
just don't need anything that has like
carbs in it but there's tons of [__]
that you can eat that's just meat or
meat vet vegetables right off the
[__] that's all I get the thing is
kind of seafood there me and Jen be
[__] bagging all kinds of [__]
gear that we're taking and [__] we
were eating until we just couldn't eat
anymore and then like [__] 20 minutes
later you feel even bigger you're like
oh [__] was like I said now we're
getting to the point where we're
stopping I just start feeling ill yeah
we're stopping if like we went to
Ichiban on Saturday I know we'll get to
the topic EV we're going to get to the
topic in a minute people eventually but
um because you know it's a food
Sidetrack that's what we this is an
intro but um the intro for an hour
before the show started yeah it's all
right everyone here is is yeah they're
all veterans
um so yeah and all I ate like literally
I can eat maybe a plate and a half and
then I'm like all right I'm going to
barf I can't like eat anymore Tom can
eat like three or four plates depending
on the day they're not filled PL yeah
depending on what it is depends on what
I mean I think last time we went I had
one plate that had salad you know just
like lettuce and tomatoes and [__] like
that and then some cold boiled shrimp
yeah um and some cocktail sauce second
place PL fish mushrooms yeah broccoli
yeah I think like an egg fu young yeah
and then that was it and then usually
for dessert I just get fruit like I get
um sometimes I'll get like a cookie cuz
they have these nice like um I'll get
cre are they almond they like almond
cookies I'll eat I'll get one almond
cookie I'll eat a whole plate of those
and some pineapp I'll eat a whole plate
of those boiled shrimp that's all
protein pure protein then I'll eat some
I'll eat like a handful of those and
I'll eat some of those damn wooden
skewers with the damn chicken thigh oh
now see those are good I get chicken th
I get those sometimes and then the uh
the beef with
[__] the Hunan beef yeah beef and
onion onion and onions and green peppers
I think yeah and I'll get a couple of
pot stickers or little won I'll get like
one oh and I I think last time I had
some wanton soup also like a little cup
of that and then I'll go get I'll go get
a soup bowl and go put in
some two scoops of [__] orange
sherbet and a scoop of damn vanilla ice
cream and big like 50/50 ice cream yeah
that's and then I'm done I I don't ever
they have a lot of good ice cream in
there but I don't ever I usually just
get a cookie and fruit like I'll usually
get pineapple and like some orange and
an orange and then like one cookie yeah
but that's it and then the next day we
went to the Indian buffet Fifth Element
and I had about a plate and a half there
and I couldn't eat anymore we ate a lot
of vegetarian there though I think I
think I ate other than I had one I had
one piece of um the what do you call it
the um tandoori chicken yeah other than
that everything I at was vegetarian I
didn't mean for it I didn't mean for
that to happen it's so it's just
everything cuz anything they do with
paneer in it is like delicious so I got
like the paneer dish and it's just but
every I think everything I got was
vegetarian whether I wanted it to be or
not yeah but yeah okay let's see what
are the comments um let me see people
have showed up Z says okay but what do
you do when you get old and your [__]
falls out well you get a new [__]
yeah you get a fake [__] this is Zach
this is gay Zack or motorcycle Zack this
gay gay Z well you know why your assho
falling out you need put it's too
[__] big you're putting big stuff up
in there man don't putting big stuff up
in there yeah don't put big stuff up in
there and pull on it you're pulling and
putting in pulling and then the [__]
fall out don't do that you're relaxing
it too
much the whole tub the whole sub genre
of like prol
is just kind like that's another thing
you could just hook up a camera all
right and and record it and try to make
money off of it I mean you might as well
yeah might as well yeah put that [__] on
[__] rotten.com or
something it's yeah then next thing you
know you got Wang talking about you
yeah yeah we've been like we've been
binging like the the super long like
Wang videos like like he's been putting
up ones that are like seven hours of
like interet mystery so it's like we'll
just put them on like in the evening and
we're just like sitting there [__]
I'm a plug Wang I'm a plug Wang show not
Wang there's a show on YouTube called
Wang w n or is it w h n g yeah I think
it is with an with exclamation point
he's pretty famous he's a great show
host and he's just got all these [__]
crazy topics he's talking about that's
where we found out about the inter the
most mysterious song on the internet
yeah we watched the whole thing about
that last night cuz he had a whole bunch
yeah he'll get into like '90s internet
[__] stories I can't watch the the
ones about the poop or the C jars or
anything yeah the animal torture videos
that makes that just grosses me out yeah
he start talking about one about where
they found a video where they set a cat
on fire and they were trying to figure
out and they would he they would show
the video but yeah he doesn't show the
[__] because he doesn't want to get to
he was going to say he was going to say
I think think it was about them trying
to find that guy who did it but man when
the descriptions of what happened
and and then I was like N I can't hear
yeah we started watching it and we were
just kind of like yeah let's know let's
let's not watch this they had one where
he talks about a dude who was paying
$150 he'd come to your house and un and
uncover your septic system and he would
set up a camera and he would go in there
and record himself swimming in your
[__] [__] tank in your subject tank
yeah he'd pay you to do it and he was
putting the videos up on YouTube before
they took him down but he shows some of
it on so he wasn't even selling him like
he was just doing that for free cuz he
was into it what a he'd get into a damn
[__] suit and swim in your
damn septic tank Tom told me about that
and just him telling me about it made me
want to throw up so I'm just like for
sure I'm not like watching that video he
had a camera set up on a tripod with
lights and everything so you could see
him nice and clear and he's [__]
floating in it and then he [__]
closes his arms and [__] goes
underneath it and then comes up like
he's in a swimming pool like I said damn
I know everybody's into different
fetishes and as long as everybody is
consenting I don't don't have a problem
with it but [__] like that literally um
I I would just rather not right so I'm
plugging Wang show if you want to do it
fine if you never heard of Wang go check
Wang out [__] subscribe to him he's a
[__] great show and he's putting up
some new videos where he like three to
seven hour comp he compiling like a
bunch of all the topics we were watching
one last night that it was all like it
was like three hours of lost media
videos he talked about like mysterious
song on the internet he talked about
like the Freddy Krueger game like video
game that was lost you can put your
headphones on fall asleep to him yeah
yeah cuz he's got a good voice he's he's
I think he's Korean korean-american I
think he's got long hair he looks like
something out of a heavy metal band I
think he he was in a heavy metal band
yeah he looks like remember remember
that [__] Mongolian band The Who hu
the who he look like something out of
that yeah that's right he looks like a
damn Mongolian [__] Warrior and [__]
he's got sleeves and [__] Zach says oh
man I love Wang he's so damn hot for one
thing yeah he's a good looking he is uh
he is rather he's a good-looking young
Korean guy I say young he's probably 35
but he looks really young yeah cuz he
keeps talking about stuff from the '90s
and the 2000s so I guess he's not as old
as we are but yeah he knows about stuff
like from then so very intell he got a
real in the 90s maybe real good voice
he's [__] funny [__] funny you
know what makes me laugh the most about
his videos is um I like when he puts
like at the beginning of the videos when
he puts his um his name and then he'll
put like a different like description of
himself like
like whatever it is having to with
whatever topic he's talking about and
they're always like super super funny so
that's kind of my favorite part but yeah
we've been watching a lot of those like
over the last few days just because we
can't think of anything else to watch to
it's like hey look you put up one that
seven hours of um you know video game
Mysteries I love it because let's watch
that I love it because the Nostalgia
Factor he always goes back to the 90s
internet and '90s stuff and I loved the
'90s you know I was already grown I was
out of the army or in the army or coming
out of the army getting married to my
first wife and just that was just a cool
decade other people don't like the '90s
I like the 90s better than the
80s um wow that's a bold statement yeah
I was too young in the 80s to actually
enjoy the 80s that was the problem you
know what I mean yeah in the 90s I was
old enough to go into clubs and stuff
yeah now late 80s I I was doing stuff
when I was in Brazil you know but I was
because I'm still working on my history
of horror movies video like I that is
coming up hopefully I'll have it up by
the end of this week I'm still I was
worked on it a lot today I was editing
it but holy [__] it's like a slow
process I'm only on the 1920s but it's
all recorded I'm just editing it so I
said in that video that it's like I
think the '90s might be my least
favorite decade for horror but then when
I was researching when I was talking
about the 2000s I was like oh wait no
maybe the 2000s might be my least
favorite decade because it's like when I
was going back into that looking at all
the movies that came out I was just kind
of like oh wait maybe this one sucked
more I'm not really sure yeah I'm not
really sure guys laughing that I
mentioned the who yeah the who is good
the who is good bad man H the who yeah
yeah it's a good Mongolian band that's
hysterical that they call them
themselves yeah they look like [__]
and then they got bikers and [__]
Mongolian bikers and they're doing the
Mongolian throat singing and there's
metal involved and [__] it's pretty good
yeah yeah yeah it's good though it's
good I like yeah
um yeah Zach said oh God I remember the
2000s being such a wasteland of horror
it really was I and like I said when I
was doing the research into it because I
you know I was around at the time and I
kind of remember what was going on um
but when you kind of go back and look at
it in aggregate like in hindsight I'm
just kind of like oh I think maybe the
2000s were worse I don't know I didn't I
still don't like the 1990s but cuz I
didn't like that whole hey let's all be
like ironically distant from the horror
movies and like everything everything
has to be ironic and funny there were
certain things about the 2000s I liked I
think the girls had cute hair the 2000s
at least at least as far as horror
movies go was like re was like remake
hell yeah when I went through there and
like looked at all the lists of all the
horror movies that had come out in that
decade I was like I don't even know what
percentage it was but a lot of them were
remakes a lot were remakes or sequels
and I was just like holy [__] [__] it
was a lot I like the 2000s as a guy cuz
uh the girls had cute hair they had
colored belts and cute pants and the
porn was
good yeah and that's pretty that's
pretty much all that um that Tom uses to
judge
yeah could it be that you just like that
more because that was like the prime
your prime age because you were at the
prime age to be watching porn [__] I'm
at the prime age right now man that's
well that's true I was going to say I go
back to you're always at the prime age I
would go back to the 2000s version of me
and kick my ass back then
I think most I think most older people
would say the same thing yeah I don't
know if I'd kick my own ass I kick my
own ass but cuz I I don't know I pretty
much have my [__] together but I would
like to kind of go back and like tell
myself not to do certain things there's
just limitations when you're when you're
that age you know I mean because I did
do some dumb [__] when I was a kid but
you know what I mean everybody does
that's kind of that's kind of I wasn't
so much doing dumb [__] is that I was
thinking dumb that too that's what I
said I don't remember being as stupid as
some people remember being but maybe
that's just me I don't really know I was
believing the dream believe in the life
oh I never did so maybe that's just kind
of why yeah I was believe I was I was
cynical from from the womb I F I would
that that's just the kind of person that
I am I think I was born that way yeah
cuz I just I don't really remember being
any different like even when I was a
child so uh you know yeah Zach said
fashion sucked back then all right so so
I have to go to the bathroom Okay and
then maybe we can get a refill of drinks
and maybe we can actually start talking
about the actual I don't have a [__] T I
don't have a [__] ton of uh of [__]
grapefruit juice I mean I got n vodka
well you can split it and then we
probably have some others don't we have
some soda and [__] like that I got some
Cola okay well that'll work okay vodka
Coke does vodka Coke actually work I've
never vodka goes with everything that's
why we get it yeah all right but I'm
going to go to the bathroom I'm going to
get some rum so you you talk for a
second okay I'm going to just try to
this is just filler time uh this whole
thing about the uh fashion in the 200000
sucking it didn't suck you can go back
in time and see what people were wearing
in the 2000s I thought even in the
movies or porn or whatever you know when
they had clothes on I I thought I
thought that was the beginning of
actually kind of like cute fashion
really especially for the girls I didn't
really care too much about what the
dudes are wearing of course you know but
I don't really judge the era by that I
judge I judge the era by what what the
girls were
wearing but uh there was [__] in the 90s
in the
2000s late 90s early 2000s I thought was
[__] cute like I liked jenkos I
[__] if I saw a girl in jenko and she
had the [__] belly shirt and [__]
pierced
belly pierced [__] belly button and
[__] [__] bar going through her
[__] tongue andit I thought that was
sexy as
[__] [__] Rave looking girls they
were just [__] [__] I liked
them and uh then later on in the early
2000s the girls were wearing [__]
pretty good pretty cute tight jeans the
cut on them was right and they had those
[__] belts they had wear a damn
leather belt that was white or a [__]
pink leather belt with [__] spikes in
it I guess it might have been a LaVine
[__] I don't know but I thought that I
thought I thought the [__] was cute you
know it kind of I thought the [__] was
cute I was still in my 30s I didn't like
AB LaVine because that was just kind of
the whole I was still in my 30s I didn't
like the whole hot top
ification of the I kind of liked it well
yeah you liked it I kind of liked it you
know what I mean I um there was just
something about I I was going to say I
thought it was cute you know so I didn't
take it seriously yeah Camp guy said I
like the high cut swimsuit legs from the
80s let me go ahead and U I'm not a fan
of those I understand like the behind it
that it makes your legs look longer
which I guess it does but I don't know I
never particularly liked that on
me
but I don't know it might look better on
me nowadays now that my thighs aren't so
fat that's maybe that's why I didn't
like them back then my thighs were super
fat um you know uh Camp guy said
lemonade is good with VI yeah it is
we've um sometimes if he is thinking
about it he'll make some Lem lemonade
and put it with vodka we actually had
that the other night he made VOD he made
lemonade with um I guess I think some
lemons that we had from the tree out
back I thought he said he made it with
that and we mixed some Voda with that it
was good it was like it was super strong
though so we had to like kind of water
it down a little
bit
um yeah Camp guy said rush and Leonard
skinnard two bands that started in their
respective high schools wonder what
their teachers thought when they became
Superstars I was kind of wondered about
that kind of stuff too
like they're just kind of like ah those
bums they'll never amount to anything
and then all of a sudden it's like oh my
God they're [__] Super Famous and
everybody knows who they are that's
crazy that's crazy all right I'm GNA
wait for Tom to come back before I get
started on the topic because I'm sure
he's going to want to like weigh in on
it but let me answer some of this stuff
back here
um let's see Danny Rowling says the
Felix is that MLA I can't quite see uh
case where he was a fighter pilot chased
after a UFO both of them crashed into
Lake Superior and supposedly both
aircrafts are still submerged under Lake
Superior um yeah I had never heard of
that story actually if we talked about
that I don't know if I would so much put
it on a military mishap show I'd
probably put it like on a UFO show I
would think Jeffy art says I tune in as
I'm diving into General so's chicken and
pot stickers oh that looks good that
sounds good actually Tom made um chicken
kma yesterday so we've been eating off
that cuz he made like a huge pot of it
so we've been eating off that for the
last couple of days it's delicious he
was actually to make chicken curry but
then like he looked he's like well my
spice mix is more like cor so I going to
make Cora it's like it's really really
good but we we had that for lunch today
but that's all we've
eaten murder Hornet City's addicted to
Cajun boiled peanuts yeah they're good
Tom loves those I I don't like I don't
like boiled peanuts on the side of the
road here yeah if but they're not cheap
man yeah Tom got some one time cuz
literally they're a whole [__] T if you
drive around Eustace cuz this is kind of
like redneck Florida if you drive around
Eustace you're going to see a little
place a little cart that's selling a
trailer boiled peanut it's like a little
trailer little trailer on the of them
truck pulling a trailer yeah and it says
[__] boiled peanuts got the signs out
on the [__] road and [__] little hand
drawn signs hand drawn signs they got
seven different flavors and you go yeah
I'm going to get spend a couple bucks on
Peanuts you go there they want [__]
eight bucks a bag and they're not that
big they're good
pickle flavor Cajun flavor
hot um just regular salted ones what
else did they have pizza I don't
remember what was that other flavor yeah
it was weird yeah that's I don't like
boiled peanuts I like I like roasted
peanuts but I don't like boiled
peanuts but yeah that's how they're
everywhere around here yeah they're
everywhere here everywhere where we at
like there's also like there's a couple
taco trucks and stuff like that too but
it's mostly boiled peanuts boiled
peanuts and watermelon in the
summertime that's mostly what they sell
motorcycle Zach is here Tom loves
expensive nuts yeah I got Zach
motorcycle Z who would have thought yeah
it was better than cheap nuts I mean
[__] like you put cheap nuts right in
their mouth wouldn't you Zach I'm going
to make motorcycle gay he wants the
fancy nuts the fancy nuts all Zachs will
be all Zachs will be gay Zachs all Zacks
are now all Zachs are now gay you
stepped in it you see what you did Z
stepped in no [__] uh motorcycle Zack
or bu Zack he's my motorcycle he's my bu
buddy right um he uh we we talk offline
he's coming down for bike week he's
going to hang out with me I'm going to
take him to Oasis we'll get some good
videos he was on this long ass [__]
drive to pick up his new bule 1190 he
bought it um [__] I think he said it
was a 10-hour drive but he got a good
deal on it 15 grand for it so yeah and
it looked like a carbon Edition this
[__] yeah showed me the picture yeah a
badass it's cool looking he's got
several bus I think he got two right the
1190 and a [__] uh xp12 SS I
think yeah y'all I don't remember when
bike week was is this year I used to
know because I grew like I said I was
born in Daytona Beach so I you had to
know because you know it's like well am
I going to be able to get to work like
around all the traffic and sub so you
had to know where the [__] was but I
don't know anymore since yeah B Zack I I
my bike week is to go to the biker bar I
don't really on my own I don't go down
to Daytona that's where the tourists
are they come here to [__] up my scene
every [__] year the locals own this
[__] okay those are the [__]
foreigners coming in here but I'll make
an exception I'll go up there with
you um you'll have a good time yeah have
a good time it is fun like cuz my dad
used to be into that stuff so we would
go down there and do some of the stuff
sometimes but yeah like when I was
growing up I went up there a couple
years back to um well he wasn't at the
[__] I met Eric Z the dude has the
turbo bule I don't know if you know
about the Eric Z's turbo bu he was down
here at sein Old Harley-Davidson with
that thing and I met him then he went on
to uh bike week I didn't go with him but
uh seol Harley-Davidson is the huge
Harley-Davidson dealership right here in
Sanford and uh for bike week they got
[__] going on there too yeah the [__]
stpp sh [__] yeah well like I said
Daytona it was just always like hey
cream corn wrestling and [__] you
know what I mean it's just it's a mad
house it's a mad
house well when I was there and this was
like years and years cuz I moved away
from Daytona a long time ago um well not
a long time ago but maybe in 2009 2010
something like that so um but prior to
that like they would have at least half
a million people yeah and it's probably
more than that now I would imagine yeah
so it's a massive massive event and um
there's just people everywhere
but it's not too bad like I said I liked
that better cuz I lived on the beach
side for a long time and bike week was a
lot easier to deal with than spring
break was I will say yeah spring break
we had people parking in our yard and
throwing up and [__] like that we didn't
really have any problem with the bikers
other than the traffic you know that was
kind of a pain in the ass but other than
that I mean you know it wasn't really
you see guys on those
damn motor custom motorcy CES with the
[__] Corvette engines in them what
was that bike called [__] they had a guy
with one of those he's like in his 60s
riding this sh late 60s maybe early 70s
[__] big ass f a cruiser with a
Corvette car engine in it I forgot what
that thing was called but it was 700
horsepower motorcycle [__] was wild I
rode right alongside him he's going slow
but yeah you should you should go to
bike week it' probably be fun for you I
think no no calling me from jail though
I mean you can call me from jail but
I'll be like bye
yeah you're on your own yeah no I would
never do that to you Tom you know that I
just do my time you're just like oh well
[__] it yeah like [__] it I get paid in
the way man [__] I make VA money they
can't take that that's true said just
pay the bills I give her she got my
account numbers I've been back in a
couple months I'm going to take a
vacation sit around eat some of his jail
food
get me a prism [__] oh he's going to
get a prison yeah [__] I'll be sporting
that [__] down the [__] tier like
check what I got yeah yeah yeah [__]
whatever I know we take pictures of it
send them to me
yeah wow we got a whole scenario like
this is we all make video together and
[__] when I get
out bitch's name is too sweet this is
too sweet oh I love it yeah that's
that's that's her prison name yeah look
we got to get to the [__] main I know
holy [__] for like almost an hour well I
don't know almost an hour but
yeah wer Z says I'm not going to jail I
like to tease Tom about it though I'm
like every time he goes like does I'm
like don't you get in trouble now I do
you call me from jail I Almost Do you're
going to be on your own yeah I say that
but it's just like I I would help
you cuz I'm I'm that kind of [__] you
know if it was something minor I'd just
do the time yeah yeah don't waste money
on me don't bond me out don't waste
money on it I don't want you to go to
jail I'll be out in a couple weeks I
would miss you yeah yeah you know what I
mean I'm just going to do my time simple
battery which probably what it would be
simple battery yeah that's the one I
gotta watch I don't know I punched a
[__] punching [__] well
I understand that I've wanted to do that
as well so so I get it yeah I've never
been to jail but I I could see how that
could happen at certain clubs that we've
been to all right so let's actually talk
about the topic for for a time and I'm
sure that you will have a lot to
contribute on this cuz this is this
military military
M we got this idea across the world yeah
we got like I said it's mostly American
but there were some other ones that I
kind of liked that I added to as well we
got this idea because of the whole uh
atomic bombs actually yeah I mentioned
it on show yeah we ad mentioned like the
atom bombs that actually been dropped
out North Carolina if anybody Army Air
Corp dropped atomic bombs on North
Carolina yeah we're going to talk about
that um by accident and so somebody said
oh my God you should do a whole show
about military mishap so I was like okay
so I put it in the poll and it won so
that's what we're that's what we're
talking about now the first one is
actually not American these are in
chronological order actually the first
one we're going to be talking about is
actually from Japan those are from
1940 this actually kind of cracked me up
and you are allowed to laugh at this
because I don't think anybody died in
this one so this is Japanese Imperial
Navy the
moushi yes yeah so here's the thing so
this was 1940 so this was prior to you
know they you know Japan was wasn't at
war with the United States or anything
like that but they still wanted to um
swing their dick around as as one does
well they were doing that yeah they were
swinging their dick in China they been
doing that for years they were whipping
ass at this time the Japanese had
Victory disease they thought they were
[__] invulnerable and their military
always a dangerous State of Affairs and
their military was much bigger than the
United States military at this time like
four times okay so a lot of people talk
about World War II we're fighting little
old Japan no Japan was had a much bigger
military force than the United States
when the war broke
out because Japan had been doing [__]
now it wasn't as in it wasn't as
mechanized they weren't as industrial
but they were a lot of men lots and lots
of men
underarms um and uh this is a tale of
the Masashi and if you know Japanese
culture you know who uh who um minamoto
Masashi was Thomas talked about oh yeah
on several I've read Masashi yeah and so
they named a battleship after so that
should tell you something right Musashi
was
a basically a Yakuza [__] swordsman
and mercenary he wasn't he wasn't of the
Samurai class I don't believe uh his D
if he was he was Dishonored his dad had
run a sword school and he learned some
[__] from his dad and his dad disowned
him they couldn't get along cuz he
really didn't pay a [__] attention to
what was going on and Masashi became
homeless and he answered the challenge a
samurai challenge to a duel at the age
of about 13 and Psychopathic ass [__]
mhi killed his first dude at the age of
13 through just pure [__]
Psychopathic rage that sounds like a
country song yeah actually uh Iron
Maiden wrote a song about it called sun
and steel off the [__] uh well there
you go of album but yeah some people
think that's about Conan it's not it's
not it's about
Masashi and uh later on he killed
probably over a hundred guys in duel and
he matured into a very good philosopher
and Warrior and he talked about the
basics of tactics and [__]
psychological warfare how to psych a
[__] out and how to live your
life as a man to make yourself into a
warrior he [__] and it was also
censored in Japan a lot of the stuff
because you had had uh Japanese uh
businessmen and corporate types reading
Masashi and trying to apply this to the
business World some of it was
[__] taken
out uh you can go on the internet you
can find where was restored Masashi said
go he said that a real Warrior [__]
will join any army even an army that
will that is destined to lose and your
job would be to uh make it win make that
Army win and and he said that you should
go where normal men Fear To
Tread okay and uh make yourself a
criminal on purpose or of purpose make
yourself a criminal on purpose and then
learn uh uh learn to get and to go to
prison and to um learn and and and and
get and talk your way out of it in other
words work your way out of going to
prison uh he said you should know all
things uh you should know the ways of
Carpenters uh order
lawmen and and organized crime he was a
[__] holistic guy San said Tom showed
me moushi should be required reading for
men exactly all men should read moushi
Japanese men do but like I said it's a
censored version of it uh [__]
didn't play and the Japanese knew that
the Japanese military uh honored him and
they made this giant Battleship called
the moushi in his is honor I love that
they name did that and that's the
[__] I laughed that's why I wanted to
include the story because that is where
the Story begins okay dude was gangster
okay yeah died of cancer of an old age
up in the damn uh cancer gets everybody
you live long they think it was stomach
cancer he got so bad at kicking
[__] asses when they would when
they would challenge him to a sword
fight he would answer the challenge with
a boat paddle and he would kill you with
a boat p battle is a form of disrespect
that's how good he got you know what
would be cooler yeah is if he said okay
well you can have a sword and stuff I'm
going to kill you with a [__] [__]
teddy bear a [__] boat paddle ted
bear he did the [__] with a boat paddle
and it's he if he could kill you with a
teddy bear then i' would be super
impressed which is all psychological
warfare he was sick of people
challenging
him so he wanted to make sure when he
killed somebody later on he wanted to
make sure it was
dishonorable to try to dissuade people
from [__] got killed with a with a
[__] boat padd beat you to death with
a [__] boat paddle and then your
family would be like oh the shame yeah
great swordsman and you can uh read most
you can hear most of his books on audio
book on YouTube but like think of how
much five rings how how much more shame
that your family would have if moushi
had killed you with like a pom pom yeah
yeah yeah or something yeah or like a
muffin yeah like that would be [__]
rad if he did that he was a badass I
have a lot of theories of why he was
better than other [__] I think
a lot of it had to do with he was
working out because he does kind of
describe that all things are hard and
over time they become easier just
because it's hard don't do not refrain
from doing it you're going to get tired
but continue to do it and that's not
wasn't the mindset of the time most most
Samurai lived lives of luxury moushi was
hard and he lived outside homeless like
a bum for a long time he says to do that
he says you should do that well it makes
everything harder makes everything
harder right that's why and he says you
should never you should always do lots
of hard labor so I think part of it was
is that Masashi was physically stronger
than a lot of
guys well and he was clearly mentally
stronger because he's actually choosing
yeah to do it to live the hardest way
possible he chose suffering over
pleasure right you over and over again
yeah so that's how the story starts they
Nam this damn badass Battleship one of
the baddest battleships to have ever
existed especially in this era you know
um it was big well it was the biggest
one at the time like this was 1940
they're like we're going to build the
biggest battleship yeah that's ever been
built up to that time in Japan and they
name it the
mashi now so not only is this the
biggest battleship ever but they're like
Well it can't be like super badass
unless it has all of these [__] like
big ass weapons on it too so it also had
a bunch of cannons on it that could
actually shoot 18in shells about 26
miles yeah and these things weighed a
lot which is yeah I think some of those
shells weighed about what a Volkswagen
Bug would weigh which is crazy [__]
crazy it's crazy to me that [__] like
that like floated yeah that still blows
my I know yeah I know how it works but
I'm still just like that seems like that
shouldn't work but I know how I know how
it does but it seems like it shouldn't
um also had a bunch of 450 mm guns on it
I believe nine of
them so yeah this was uh outfitted yeah
to the Max and it was like I said the
biggest battleship they'd ever made up
to this point and the Japanese Imperial
Navy was probably one of the best navies
to ever in modern times one of the best
na navies ever they were good they were
extremely good very well
educated um their guys were well drilled
trained and and uh so these guys weren't
dumb asses Japan was a great Naval power
in this era yeah I mean like I said the
point of the show I don't want to like
cast dispersions on everyone on anyone's
military everybody makes mistakes um
everybody does dumb [__] everybody [__]
up you know what I mean so it's just
kind of funny to like laugh about it
because the reason that people laugh
about these cuz it Doesn't Really Happen
that often you know what I mean but the
hilarious thing about this story
was that they're like okay we have the
biggest battleship ever we called it the
moushi about the you know after the
biggest badass that ever existed like in
Japan we put all these big [__] guns
on it it's this massive and like oh my
God this is going to be the best thing
ever okay so one thing they apparently
did not consider however was how much
this Battleship
weighed so they did the launch right
into the
sea now when they put it out to sea when
they launched it this Battleship
displaced
63,000 tons of water and caused a tidal
wave which flooded all the coastal areas
of Nagasaki so it not only capsized all
the boats in the harbor when they
launched it but it also flooded all the
houses and the stores along Ong the
coast of Nagasaki and the funny thing
about it is that nobody knew what was
going on so everybody that like lived
there or you know ran a shop there or
whatever they all came running out cu
they're like why is all this water
coming in our [__] house or our place
of business and the Navy was too
embarrassed to tell them what had
happened so they were just kind of like
yeah it was just that kind of situation
they didn't really know now I don't
think anybody got killed um but
obviously there was a lot of property
damage because a lot of the houses and
shops along the um Coast were [__] up
because they were flooded um and also
all the boats in the harbor also
capsized so there was that too so like I
said kind of funny like the battleship
did go on to you know do Battleship
things but the funny thing about it was
that when it launched they were just
kind of like oh oopsie yeah and then
like they kind of lied about it because
they were just kind of embarrassed about
I don't think the mashi survived the war
though or was I think may be think of
the Yamato the mashi did go down is this
what we're talking about how the mashi
went down uhuh we not okay
okay yeah I'm not really um yeah I don't
really know what happened to it it
eventually went down eventually believe
it went down [__] through from uh
Torpedoes I think yeah I well a lot of
them did yeah and if I remember
correctly somebody might be able to uh
drop in the comment section I believe
the yato was the sistership excuse me I
believe that the Sashi was the sister
ship to the yato I think they were the
same ship mechanically just named
differently I'm not sure Yamato went
down too yeah a lot of ships did they
were good ships though they were real
good in their time yeah yeah it's just
it sounds funny now yeah but it's like
like I said as far as I know the Masashi
like you know uh performed admirably
like for whatever it's Duty was and
everything like that but it's just like
when they launched it apparently they
didn't really take into consideration
how much it weighed because they had
never built a battleship of this size
before so when they launched it it
flooded okay the whole town like not the
whole town so that's the mishap yeah
yeah okay all right yeah I got all right
and capsized all the boats and it
capsized all the boats yeah so big it
[__] it drowned it drowned the
coastline yeah and cap which you think
they would have thought of they didn't
think about it they didn't think about
it it could have been
propaganda
might have been our ship our ship is so
[__] huge that when we put it into
water it [__] the sea level rose that
would be funny like that would be like
some a good lie like later on like
especially like after if it got sunk or
something like that like they would come
up with some story it's like this ship
was so badass it's like we flooded a
whole [__] town with this [__] that's
how big it was yeah okay cuz it caused a
[__] Title Wave it did it was a 4
foot Title Wave but that's still a Title
Wave It's still like flooded the area
around there and like I said capsized
all the boats so yeah mashi didn't
survive the war
yeah um Zan said the Yamato went down
American pilot sunk it okay did the
mashi go down I think it did if I
remember correctly I think all of the
big ones were sunk thank you Ian England
thank you very much he says skull thank
you very much I'm not sure if I'm
pronouncing that correctly skull skull
PR skull yeah salute yeah yeah Z said
got destroyed too all the big ships got
destroyed yeah I thought they did I
thought they did uh Dan rolling said the
Philadelphia exper Experiment is the
biggest military mishap yeah we did a
whole show about that though like sure
that actually happened it's like yeah
said Zan said yeah that Masashi went
down yeah I thought it had I thought it
had like I said I was just thought it
was funny that it when it launched and
it flooded all the [__] it flooded
everybody because it was too big and
they didn't think about it but like I
said you know what I mean people make
mistakes all right so the next thing I
want to talk about this is an American
story now this I don't know if Tom knows
about this but this I had never heard
this story before and this is
crazy so this is about this is from 1943
the story like I said these are in
chronological
order and this is about a destroyer
called the USS William D Porter or the
wiie D for short which is what they
called it now this is supposedly the
unluckiest ship to have ever existed and
reading its
the [__] that happened on it really it
was only in existence from when it was
um you know kind of launched or whatever
um to when it was sunk I believe it was
only like two years but all kind of
crazy [__] happened in like those two
years and it's and I will admit yeah
some of it was accidents but a lot of it
was human error also which is why I
thought this story was very funny even
though at least one person died during
the story so I'm just telling you ahead
of
time um so yeah so this ship we're
talking about the USS William D Porter
do you know about that the wiie D as
they called
it I did not know this story either and
this is crazy okay so this was in
1943 so this that's when the ship was
you know commissioned or built or
whatever and it was one of um you know
they just built they built destroyers on
an assembly line back then um it wasn't
as big as mod day destroyers are but you
know it was still pretty impressive for
the time um it had uh 10 Torpedoes that
carried 500 lb warheads and also had
anti-aircraft artillery weapons on
it so this was ship was commissioned um
in July of
1943 um under the command of Lieutenant
Commander Wilfred a
Walter now now the first big assignment
that this Destroyer had in November of
1943 was she was supposed to accompany
another Battleship called the Iowa on
some secret mission across the Atlantic
now the crew of the porter didn't really
know what the details of the secret
mission were because it was secret so
they were just kind of like hey you're
going to go with the Iowa and just do
what we tell you you know what I mean
now the Iowa it should be noted was
carrying
the then US President Franklin Delano
Roosevelt also the secretary of state
whose name was Cordell Hull and a whole
bunch of like kind of highlevel Military
Officers now so the crew members were
kind of like okay they knew what they
they they were on like a need to know
basis I guess so they like knew what
they had to know but it's pretty clear
that I'm not really sure where they got
the crew of this thing I don't want to
disparage like people that are long dead
or something like that but there were a
lot of fuckups on this some of it was
accidents okay but like I said some of
it was human
error so they set out now all of the
[__] that happened started the night
before she was supposed to go out on
this uh Trek with the
Iowa now while the wiie D was trying to
kind of maneuver out of like in the port
or whatever it actually ran into another
ship like it backed into to the side of
it and this took down like the anchor of
it like took down a bunch of other like
railings and the captain's gig and all
kind of stuff like on the other ship
right now the wiie D was really not they
just had a couple scratches and stuff
like that but it was kind of um let's
say that this was just kind of like a a
Prelude of things to come thank you very
much Aaron late admission fee loving
your book reviews Jenny thank you so
much I just got another email today like
where some of them sent me an arc and
it's like a fantasy like a dark fantasy
which I don't usually read but I don't
know I usually do try to read stuff that
people send to me for free so I might do
that one next but I can't remember what
it's called right now but it might take
me a while to read it we'll see cuz like
I said if you weren't here at the
beginning which I'm imagining you
weren't because you said late fee um I
got a full-time job so I'm starting on
Monday so I'm probably going to have to
confine my movie and book reviews to
like the weekends cuz I'm not going to
have time to stream them on weekdays
anymore but yeah so we'll see how it
goes but thank you very much I really
like doing this book reviews and movie
reviews
also so yeah so so even before they went
out on the ship they backed into another
boat and [__] it all up right so there
was that about a day later after
everything was kind of sorted out um the
wiie D the Iowa and two other
destroyers they set saale for
Africa now on this journey they were
under very very strict orders to
maintain complete radio silence because
there were a lot of like German uots in
the area right so they were just kind of
hoping to kind of sneak across the ocean
no one's going to see the [__] you know
what I mean so they're just going to
like just keep it [__] quiet very
very strict orders however not too long
into The Journey there was a um there
was an explosion in the in the water
that kind of all the boats were just
kind of like you know what I mean it was
like that it turns out that the captain
uh of of the wiie D says um my bad a
depth charge fell off the stern of the
Willie D uh the safety on the charge had
not been set which like I said was uh
human airor and when it crashed into the
water it detonated and it made all the
ships kind of [__] up you know what I
mean so there was
that so soon after this depth charge was
accidentally detonated there was this
big wave that smashed into the side of
the Willie D um and everything that was
on the ship that wasn't nailed down
pretty much got swept off including one
dude uh and they never found him so like
I said that that dude
died um also
because of the wave they lost all the
power in one of the boilers so you know
this mission's not going so great uh
obviously now a little bit later while
they're still on the same Mission this
is November 14th 1943 so the four ships
are going um they're a little bit east
of
Bermuda now the president FDR who was on
the Iowa the other the accompanying uh
ship he said say he wanted
to test the defenses of the Iowa the
ship that he was on just in case
somebody attacked them you know what I
mean just for shits and giggles perhaps
or he's just like Hey we're going to see
how how well you guys do so the crew of
the Iowa they're doing like a you know
an
exercise so they launch a bunch of
weather balloons um to represent
anti-aircraft
targets and then they start started
firing their the guns at
them now the guy Walter that was in
charge of the Willie D well he's like
well I want to get on this [__] too so
he also starts he sends all his men to
their Battle Stations because he's like
woo it's this is going to be super fun
we're going to like pretend it's a big
battle or something like that so the
crew of the wiie D starts shooting at
whatever balloons the you know the crew
of the Iowa had missed like when they
were shooting
and they were kind of kind of coming
toward their
ship now they were also going to do some
fake torpedo shots toward the Iowa the
Iowa at this point was about 6,000 yards
away from them in the sea now obviously
when they're doing um these kind of fake
these
exercises uh they'll take out the
primers for the Torpedoes like for
practice you know what I mean however
one of the torpedo
guys
forgot um to remove the primer from one
of the torpedo
tubes so just as this one
torpedo um you know the the guy that was
ordering the hey we're doing the
exercise like shoot the Torpedoes which
were supposed to be like not like fake
you know what I mean um so he says okay
like
fire and uh one of the Torpedoes which
was was
armed uh went across the sea toward the
Iowa right toward the ship that had the
president of the [__] United States
on it heading right toward
it now apparently according to a person
that was there like uh you know some
stories that were told much later on the
crew of the Willie D were freaking out
as you would because was like holy [__]
we just launched a live [__] torpedo
at the president of United States
including several other military very
higher ups so not great so they start
running around like chickens with their
hands cut off um trying to get like or
like there's just conflicting orders
they don't know what the [__] is going
on they're just like okay what are we
going to do we have to contact the ship
but we had to maintain radio silence
like I said because of the German uat
uots and all that kind of stuff so they
said okay well maybe we can do like
flashing lights you know what I mean
like you know SOS type signal or
something like that um so they did that
but they did them in the wrong direction
uh because you know this was kind of
like a a farce at this
point and at that stage they were like
okay well we're just going to go into a
full speed
reverse and so they start doing that and
they're like look we have to break the
radio silence we have to tell the Iowa
that there's like a live torpedo L
heading toward them because the [__]
president is on that ship right so they
did that they did notify the Iowa just
it it was like in a movie it was just
like at the last minute you know what I
saying now the cool thing this is how
badass FDR was so when he he heard the
news that it's like hey there's a live
torpedo coming toward the ship right now
and you're probably going to die he said
well can you roll my wheelchair over to
the railing so I can look at it that's
what he said he wanted to go like I
guess he wanted to see the torpedo that
was going to kill him or whatever um now
at this stage I think that the crew of
the Ohio of the Iowa were kind of
thinking that maybe whoever was on the
wiie D like are they wanted to
assassinate him or what the [__] is
going on so they turned all of their
guns toward the wiie D because there's
like is there somebody on board that's
you know that's doing this you know what
I mean however it h luckily happily um
the torpedo ended up detonating um in
the water like cuz there were when when
the wiie D like sped up and it made like
all these waves and and everything uh
the torpedo hit that and it blew up
before it got to the ship so that was
kind of
Lucky
now so when they got back to uh port or
or whatever the entire crew of the wiie
D was placed under arrest and then were
then sent to Bermuda to face trial this
is the first time I don't know if it was
the last time but it was the first time
in Naval History that entire crew of a
ship was arrested all at one time so
there was that now it so happened that
the guy that had
forgotten um the whole primer in the
torpedo deal he said yeah um I
accidentally left the primer in the
torpedo tube and I didn't want anybody
to know about it so then he threw the
primer off the side of the ship like he
did confess to that later
on um so a lot of the stuff was actually
not released a lot of this info was not
released to the public until later on
because I get you know it's embarrassing
or whatever now the dude with the prime
that threw the primer other side of the
ship he actually got sentenced to 14
years hard labor
damn um the rest of the crew uh they all
got fired essentially um their military
careers were ended but FDR which is kind
of magnanimous of him considering they
almost killed his ass um he kind of came
in and said hey like don't punish them
it was just a bunch of accidents which
kind
of but you know what I mean like I said
that was kind of cool of him to come in
and say he you know just just leave him
alone even though they almost killed
with a torpedo
accidentally so all of that nonsense
happened now the wiie D then they were
like okay they assigned the ship to the
uan islands uh you know in the Northern
Pacific up by Alaska and this was just a
simple Patrol Mission they're like just
go up there like maybe you can't cause
any trouble up
there but even before it went to that
assignment um they accidentally off the
ship AC accidentally shot a 5 in
artillery shell um into the front yard
of the commandant of uh who was lived on
the American base on the islands so on
the componants lawn yeah pretty much
which you sh like I said this is like a
[__] movie have they made a movie of
this it would be [__] hilarious I
mean it's just like this it's like the
[__] they're like the Keystone Cops
like they can't do anything right and
it's just kind of like so [__] fun
like you know other than that one dude
that got swept out to se like that's not
funny but it's just kind of like other
than that it's like everything was just
like they just couldn't get anything
right so after that uh the ship got
assigned to uh okanawa Japan now while
it was there they did actually because
they had anti-aircraft uh you know stuff
uh Hardware on there so they actually
did shoot down a bunch of J Japanese
aircraft unfortunately they also shot
down three American aircraft that'd be
easy to do though and well the
reputation got around so much so that
like other Americans on the base like
every time they saw somebody that was on
the wiie D they're just like don't shoot
it that's how bad it was yeah because
the ship had a reputation by this point
no guided missles back in those days
they just [__] shot [__] up in the
air and anything was moving I mean so if
you ever seen any films of the World War
II St
Naval Aviation combat yeah it'd be
really easy to shoot down friendly
planes it's hard to tell them apart
they're just little dots it's just like
it's a plane yeah just shoot at it yeah
let God sort him out right but yeah it's
like I get that but
still after all of the [__] that sh bad
luck ship this is a bad luck ship yeah
it's like Slip Rock it is it's just it's
hilarious and I'm sure that like most of
the crew on there were perfectly
competent but it just seemed like no
they were comp it was just this is just
a bunch dumb [__] and it's just a bunch
of [__] accidents happening right
like you know what I mean and stupid
mistakes and [__] like that that led to
like larger things it's like it's going
to happen to one of the ships it can
happen you know you know something like
this is going to happen to one of the
ships in your name and that just
happened to be the one happened to be
the
one oh but that's not all yeah what else
happened so uh so yeah so like I said
the joke got around it's like hey don't
shoot me you know what I mean like all
the Americans and stuff yeah on June
10th
1945 uh there was actually a fully
loaded kamakazi
plane um and it snuck into US
airspace and it was trying to crash the
plane into a ship that was near the
Willie
D but whatever for whatever reason at
the last moment it kind of like veered
off course and crashed not into the
Willie D but like along side of it like
right next to it uh the plane sunk and
then
exploded and that tore open the ship's
Hall and the wiie D sank damn so that's
kind of how it ended so it was almost
two years less than two years right uh
the ship was [__] around and all of
that [__] happened in just those short
less than two years I bet you the US
Navy has never again christened a shiped
a ship after that calling it that we're
not calling it that yeah the William D
Porter was what it was called but they
called it the wiie D for a short it's
like yeah that name is cursed we're just
not calling it that I read that story
and I'm just like I can't even believe
that that really happened in real life
that is [__] crazy like I said they
should make a movie out of that yeah
Tammy said it was a comedy of errors
that's exactly what it was like like I
said other than that one dude that died
which like I said that's sad because he
just got swept off but other than that
everything was just kind of a series of
close calls and all that kind of [__]
because cu the thing about it was that
when the um when the kamakazi plane like
exploded underneath the Willie D and it
sank all of the crew survived nobody
died um so I guess you could say that
was lucky but yeah so nobody died during
that so that's good at least but man I
can't imagine what it like to be to be a
crew member on that ship and like cuz
like I said it started getting a
reputation like pretty quickly because
of all of this crazy [__] [__] that
happened all right so um so the next
story we want to talk about this is the
one that gave us the idea to do this
show in the first place and I don't know
if a lot of people know I didn't know
about this until fairly recently but
there was a time uh a night in
1961 when two atomic bombs fell on North
Carolina happily and obviously neither
of them detonated
but uh it did happen so this was the
story that kind of um I think Tom said
said something about it one night and I
was like oh yeah and I looked it up and
I was like holy [__] I never they don't
teach you that in history class so uh
yeah and that was what gave what gave us
the idea to do this so we're talking
about the atomic bombs on North Carolina
yeah yeah yeah yeah this is probably one
of the biggest mishaps of all time like
I said this [__] Could Happen oopsie
well like I said it could have gone a
lot worse so we're just lucky that it
didn't turn it almost did yeah that's
what I mean and it's only like this is
kind of the thing where yeah it was
unlucky that that happened but it was
like Lucky in another Direction because
there was a lot of things that could
have very easily gone wrong and uh [__]
would have been a lot different nowadays
and get some more ice in this so this
happened January 24th
1961 so there was a Boeing B52 Strat
Fortress and they were doing just a
regular routine flight along the
coastline of the
Carolinas so North Carolina has a bunch
of military bases in the state so this
was you know a fairly a common thing to
happen like they were always kind of
like flying around you know what I
mean now on this particular
aircraft uh there were eight people that
was uh the crew and there were also two
H bombs hydrogen bombs um this was also
fairly common during the era which like
I said I think a lot of people didn't
know back then 1961 in North Carolina
you didn't know that there were like
planes with h bombs on them like flying
right over your house all the time but
they were you didn't people didn't know
that till
later so what happens Midway during the
flight this very routine
flight the
aircraft had a fuel
leak now the pilot who is in command of
the aircraft he tries to like he would
would um burn the fuel off uh before
trying to land he was going to land at a
closer like at Seymour Johnson Air Force
Base way you're Landing with less fuel
so there's less less chance of exploding
or fire or anything like that so that's
what he was trying to
do but while he was in the uh midst of
doing that um the rightwing of the plane
failed and the plane started losing
altitude and started like breaking apart
which is bad uh if you've never it's bad
plan breaks apart that's yeah that's
that's always a bad sign that's a red
flag yeah it's like I'm in this thing
I'm flying through the air there's
aerodynamic are falling off should I be
alarmed yes you should be alarmed yeah
there aerodynamic properties involving
lift and you're losing your wings yeah
yeah bad you kind of need those yeah
yeah just a pro tip so yeah so it starts
basically like falling apart so um the
crew begin to eject now this one like I
said sorry to say some people did die in
this one uh five of the crewmen uh did
successfully eject um you know they
landed safely another one ejected but
didn't survive uh the landing and two of
the crew died in the crash now this
plane uh basically broke into pieces it
disintegrated and crashed into the
ground now as the main part of the plane
the fuselage um heads toward the ground
I guess because there was centrifugal
forces pulling on everything in the
plane so
somehow the arming mechanisms the steps
for arming the H bombs on board where
there were two of them like I said they
activated um now the two bombs separated
from the plane and they fell into a
field near goldboro North
Carolina now the first bomb uh it had a
parachute on it and so the parachute
opened and it fell intact there's
actually a picture of it I used it on
one of the um on the thumbnail so it's
just like sitting there the parachute
got caught in a tree so it's just kind
of like sitting there in the ground now
the bomb's like safe switch was still in
the safe
position but the rest of the arming
sequence had happened yeah it could have
gone off so they're like basically this
one switch not going off was the only
thing that prevented this bomb from
detonating yeah in Goldsboro North
Carolina was this a gun type bomb or
spherical implosion do you know oh I'm
not sure
okay how that [__] usually went the
easiest is probably spherical
implosion where you have two nuclear
materials a core and an outer shell and
a bunch of plastic explosives around
that and
if the conditions are right when the
fuses tell the plastic explosives to go
on it collapses the outer shell onto the
inner core critical mass is reached it
blows there were some safeties in there
to keep
those uh plastic explosives from being
triggered they all were broken except
one yeah it could have gone off
now sounds awful scary there are people
out there that think that if one atomic
bomb goes off then the entire world well
this was a hydrogen bomb it was a
hydrogen bomb still that if one hydrogen
bomb goes off then oh man the whole
world is [__] no we [__] set off
hundreds of those things above ground
during tests a lot of them on a place
called bikini atle and other countries
did it
too had it gone off I don't think there
would have been very many casualties
but that's [__] embarrassing a little
that an atomic or a hydrogen bomb goes
off because a plane crash because
hydrogen bomb is worse than atomic bomb
yeah yeah cuz it's several times more
power same thing it's just that uh heavy
water or hydrogen is around the inner
[__] core of the two uranium or
plutonium whatever the heavy metals are
that they're going to do or heavy or
nuclear materials that they're going to
use around it you can shell it with
hydrogen um and hydrogen Burns a lot
more effect efficiently in a nuclear
fire which makes the explosion
bigger but here's something else I want
to [__] tell you
people if you double the power of an
atomic bomb it doesn't get twice as big
it only gets like maybe 25% big
bigger a lot of a lot of the fear of the
atomic bomb bomb and nuclear weapons was
propaganda uh a lot a lot of it was
American propaganda to to scare the
Soviets still not a good idea you don't
want hydrogen bombs going off on
friendly ground uh no I they not tell me
what could happen I don't even think
that needs to be said yeah there there
is Fallout which is when you have the
nuclear fire if it touches the ground it
breaks the ground up into [__]
subatomic particles that go floating
through the atmosphere and they're
carcinogens if you breathe them it could
kill you um it takes time for them to
kill you but you you might die let's say
you get hit at 20 you might die at 50 or
60 of
cancer that that was the typical kind
it's still not fun you know not fun all
right
uh but yeah this is a [__] big this
is a big
accident the upside of this story is
that because of this the US Air Force or
the US Army Air Corp was it the air core
or the Air Force at this time not sure
not
sure uh ended up changing the safety
protocols where they well I would hope
so they wouldn't move these things by
air cuz they used to do this all the
time I don't know if you guys know this
this was 1961 this was fairly 61 it's 61
is the Air Force right okay yeah then uh
uh [__] yeah they Chang they changed
it they started to move them by Rail and
by
Truck moving them by air can be risky
yeah probably safer even though it's
more likely like for trains and cars uh
you know to be in an accident than a
plane but it's not a high velocity not
right that's what I mean it's not the
same as like a plane it's not yeah going
hundreds of miles under the ground right
yeah you know what I mean yeah where
it's more likely to go off yeah the the
risk with ground transport is hijacking
yeah I actually knew a guy in the Air
Force his job was to be a member of one
of the security teams that would escort
nuclear weapons that were being
transported he said above
ground I don't know
man there are a lot of tunnels under the
underneath un tunnels you'd think they
would utilize those where I have a
feeling there are secret tunnels just
for safety reasons which like I said I
would Advocate that if they if they have
that available um I once saw another
program on a cable television program I
think it was History Channel that said
that and one of the commentators said
that if you look at the American road
map of the surface he says it's about
like that
underground oh I believe it yeah and
there's been enough time and uh there's
been [__] they were doing [__] back
in World War II connecting Washington DC
to to to to New York with secret
underground railroads train tracks
places to [__] Evacuate the president
that kind of [__] there's no telling
what's underground I mean I would be
shocked if they didn't have stuff like
that so I'm sure there's underground
roads yeah we we would never know about
that they're transporting nuclear
weapons and
stuff from one base to another it's too
dangerous to fly
them and it's yeah I wouldn't risk it
even though yeah flying is statistically
safer than ground transportation but
just the fact of if one plane crashes
that shit's probably going to blow up
it's a huge embarrassment and they're
the thing is is that they're spending
taxpayer money so from their point of
view it's free money and they have
tunneling technologies that you can't
imagine they have these [__] damn
things looks like a damn round space
capsule with a [__] D crunching drill
on the front and Treads on the bottom
and it can [__] move forward hundreds
of yards a day you know through solid
rock uh tunneling machines so I imagine
I imagine that by this time this this
time to Imagine by 200 what is it 24 now
it is yeah yeah 20124 which is crazy I
never thought imagine there's [__] I
never thought I'd still be alive in this
year imagine there's a [__] ton of
[__]
secret underground tunnels connecting
military bases that we that we don't
know
about like I said I would be surprised
if they didn't have that because if it
was me and I had all the money like I
would have that yeah why would you not
they have all the money and they had a
lot of time and they had access to
nuclear power so you could take some of
those
tunneling tunneling technology put a
nuclear reactor in it out of a submarine
and [__] probably bore some badass
[__] tunnels through the Earth
without having to worry about fuel or
anything Danny says the difference
between hydrogen and atomic one makes a
whistle noise and the other is sung by
Blondie I love that blondie song I love
that blond it's a good song it is a good
song Atomic I always I always dance to
it when they when they play it at the
80s bar yeah um yeah Zan said they set
off a [__] ton of nukes here in Nevada
where I live there's one town in Nevada
that had a 100% increase in children
getting cancer but they never linked it
to anything could have been from those
nukes I mean probably
probably yeah Nevada was a testing
ground oh big time Big Time for a lot of
[__] yeah so we talked about the first
bomb so one switch pretty much made it
from like kept one safety switch one
safety switch kept from going up yeah
the second bomb the second bomb came out
of the plane it was also partially armed
and it basically like like fell into the
ground like you know going fast 100
miles hour uh it landed in a field that
was like full of mud and disintegrated
thankfully it did not
detonate there was one high voltage
switch on it that they believe prevented
it from arming fully and they think that
this is the only reason that this bomb
did not explode 24 megatons this bomb
was pretty big two bombs
yeah fell on North
Carolina yeah and thankfully did not
explode they very very well could have
but Megs 24 Megs is a lot bigger than
the Hiroshima bomb in ter these were
yeah and like I said hydrogen bombs are
generally a lot more powerful than
atomic bombs yeah now the size like I
said before the size of the explosion
isn't quite the same but still that's a
lot more power a lot more e the [__]
got fast isn't the difference between
between them isn't one like a fision
bomb and one is like a fusion bomb no uh
well yeah there is f fision and fusion
but I don't I don't know all the
technical details a lot of that [__] is
[__] nuclear [__] secrets I mean
that's what most of most my most of them
I believe is
fision most but I think hydrogen bombs
are Fusion bombs it could be yeah I know
all I know about the hydrogen is that
whatever they have like a much larger
impact like over a wider area than a the
same it's the same basic core where you
have like uranium and plutonium smacking
into each other and the the way that
around it they react to each other is
different well it's because around it
there's a u a whole bunch of hydrogen
fuel which fuels the
explosion that that's the main
difference based on memory yeah yeah I'm
just saying from my understanding I
think that a fusion bomb is like many
times worse in the sense of
um having a much
larger uh impact radius yeah you know
what I'm saying yeah we have it hydrogen
around it has has probably more because
I think like the way that the um the
atoms like react to each other is I
think the the deciding factor there I
just know that the hydrogen was a
fuel basically to get it hotter which
meant more
powerful yeah so yeah if you live in
North Carolina just just know that in
1961 y'all could have basically got
nuked yeah I mean you did get nuked you
just you just didn't know about it they
didn't go off didn't go off yeah um
which like I said I can see why they
didn't tell people that [__] until like
later on cuz I didn't know until later
secret they don't tell you that in
History Class yeah it's a secret I think
Tom told me about it yeah or I read it
somewhere and I was just like holy [__]
really like I might have read it I I
think it was on one of those cracked
articles yeah that was just kind of like
crazy military it was a secret for
decades it was yeah and then they
finally Declassified it and by that time
the our bad it was it was a long time
ago so we dropped a couple H bombs on
you guys sorry yeah so there was they
didn't go off though so don't some
people don't add us some people would
have died had they gone off oh big time
but not as many as You' probably think
maybe a thousand or so probably I mean
that's still a lot still a lot that's
still a lot of people cuz it wasn't in
the middle of a city where they hit
thankfully I mean that easily could have
happened too yeah so here's the thing so
they were going to do an excavation of
the second bomb but they cuz you know
cuz like I said the first one the pit
was it was right there it's like I have
a picture of it it's like basically
right there because it had the parachute
on it it got caught in a tree so it was
they found it but the second one fell in
like the mud and it was going really
fast so it like way down into the mud
they never found it um yeah so what
happened was yeah there was a bunch of
ground flooding and and the crews had to
call off the
excavation uh they did find the core of
the bomb okay um so they recovered that
but they never did recover the secondary
core okay which had um the thermonuclear
that you know that had all the uranium
and plutonium oh they never found that
huh cuz that was like way underground
and they never could find it it weighed
more yeah so they never could find that
so it's still there if you live in North
Carolina um yeah but you wouldn't be
able to get it no I know yeah but I'm
just saying it's like if you go to that
place now there is a sign they have like
a little uh you know those little signs
they have like for hisory like this is a
historical site that this and that
happen they do actually have a sign
there now that says hey we dropped some
uh H bombs on you people like it says
that um you know it it says that now and
there's just kind of like trees and dirt
and there's like some kind of discolored
grass yeah um
but if you live in that area I I hate to
tell you but that secondary core it
that's [__] is still under there it's
still there but uranium comes out of the
earth anyway so that's not they're not
worried about that it's still there now
there's um there are nuclear powered
submarines sitting on the bottom of the
ocean with nuclear weapons in them that
have [__]
sank but you can't get to them yeah you
know and
um if you were to go down there today
and reclaim those nuclear weapons off
those sunken submarines you wouldn't be
able to use them but you could because
it would be too damaged long too too
long ago but you probably could Salvage
the the nuclear materials you know what
I mean the uranium yeah and probably
fashion them into a new bomb but you got
to know what you're doing only a nation
state or a person with billions of
dollars has the tools to make a bomb the
measurements have to be perfect don't
[__] around with that and you have to
know exactly don't try to build that
[__] in your garage yeah no you couldn't
do it if there's any problem in the
measurements okay but uh if there's any
problem at all what you'll have is you
have it this
fizzle it's called a nuclear fizzle
there's no explosion it's just that the
the two masses strike each other and it
just kind of
it does release a bunch of R
radioactivity but it's not an
explosion or it may be an explosion but
a very weak
one I have literally never in my life
thought to myself hey I should maybe
build a bomb yeah I have never that has
never well North Korea did that uh one
of their early they did nuclear tests
was
called was uh not successful they said
it fizzled which means it and it's just
a very slight
miscalculation in terms of science [__]
you got to get that [__] right you got
to get it just right we go the rest it's
hard to
do but like you know don't do that I'm
just saying don't be building UPS I
still can't
believe that and like I said I think the
fact the reason why they didn't tell
people about this for a long time even
though it happened in 1961 was because
they didn't want people to know that
they were routinely flying planes with h
bombs on them over North Carolina like
all the time all the time so I think
that people would have been like
bothered because I would have been
bothered I don't want some playing with
[__] H bombs I flying over my house
regularly you know they could drop that
[__] right into my roof I don't I don't
want that to happen so I kind of feel
like that's why they didn't want to tell
anybody so I didn't know anything about
this until fairly recently I don't know
if it was classified and it was recently
Declassified ified but um you know
honestly I only found out about it very
very recently like maybe like a year or
two ago that that happened uh so yeah so
here's another similar case
where an American plane that had uh H
bombs on it
crashed and it actually had four nuclear
bombs on it it did not crash in the
United States it actually crashed in
Greenland which if you are uh aware is a
friendly
country so that was a whole thing too so
this was also a B52 this happened in
1968 also in
January so I don't know if Tom knows
about this one the B52 that crashed in
Greenland with four nuclear bombs on it
yeah I four h bombs yeah I vaguely so
it's a similar kind of case although
this worked out a lot
worse so not a lot worse but worse so
this happened in 1968 so this is an
American again a b-52g stri of Fortress
it was a bomber it had four nuclear
bombs on
it now the bomber uh the call sign was
hobo
28 the plane crashed into Greenland into
a fjord actually the Walston home Fjord
uh which is in the northwest corner of
Greenland now um this area is part of
Denmark so the Danes who are an ally of
the United States were like not amused
which we'll get into so this bomber H oo
or hobo
28 what did happen here's why it crashed
and this is why this is a military
mishap human
error so one of the crew members for
whatever reason I'm sure he had some
reason but he stuffed a bunch of seat
cushions in front of a heating vent I I
don't know
why and um not surprisingly they caught
fire got too hot yeah I I don't know why
he did that I don't know if he wasn't
thinking about it or he know that was a
heat vent or I don't I don't know what
the problem was he's like Comfort it's
too hot in here I'm just gonna I'm going
to block off the maybe he thought he
could block the heating vent yeah and
with something super flammable I mean
even I know better than that come on
so they did that now the smoke got so
bad in the plane that the crew had to
eject now so six of the seven crew
members uh ejected and parachuted out
safely uh the seventh one sorry to say
did not make it uh the plane crashed
into the
Fjord now this Fjord that they crashed
into was seven miles west of the THU Air
Base which is America's
most northern military base thu thu 700
miles north of the Arctic
Circle wasn't THU the name of the
society that [__] eventually what I
thought gave birth to the Nazis yeah it
was yeah th
yeah tle yeah but I'm sure that means
other things they were esoteric [__]
groups this is an esoteric Air Force
Base the esoteric Air Force Base
esoteric Germanic [__] groups yeah
yeah well I mean I think they named it
that because it means something else in
right it must mean something in that
yeah it it doesn't have anything to do
with Nazis or anything like
that um so yeah now obviously like
Greenland if you didn't know is um
pretty strategically important to the
American Military uh particularly at
this time because it was pretty much
exactly halfway between Moscow and
Washington DC um so in
1946 uh the US had actually tried to buy
it from Denmark Greenland that is um
Denmark said
nah but um they said but I tell you what
you guys can put an air base there
that's fine they didn't they didn't let
them buy the whole country though you
know what I mean we're trying to like
buy everything what's that all
about so what happened so plane crashes
with four hydrogen
bombs in
Greenland now because this had happened
uh the Danes were a little
miffed now Denmark had um since
1957 had established a nuclear-free Zone
policy and they did not want any nuclear
weapons in Denmark or its
territories now
this crash at the THU Air
Base had uh exposed the fact that the US
had been flying planes armed with
nuclear weapons over their airspace for
a long time even though the US was
telling them that they hadn't so the
Danes were a little uh pissed off about
it as you would
be um and the fact that this plane had
crashed into a fjord um and some of the
bombs had broken apart
had actually like caused radioactive
contamination in the area so they were
again a little pissed off about it uh
because what happened was that when the
plane crashed um there was a fire and
the weapons had broken open and like
released all the radioactive [__] um
they didn't blow up thankfully but they
did like contaminate the area so as I
said these were H bombs and like we were
talking about before it's like a lot
worse than
uh atomic bombs that were dropped on
Hiroshima nagasaka not saying that those
weren bad but these were like several
times worse um these were okay so the
example I wrote down was that uh the
bombs that were on this particular plane
that crashed into Greenland the bombs
were a 100 times more
powerful than the bombs dropped than the
bomb dropped on um Hiroshima okay 100
times more powerful like I said they did
not detonate but they did break apart
and kind of leeched into the environment
so what 50 megatons um something like
that 1400 kilotons Kil 1400 kilotons
kilotons is what it was all right um the
bomb the bomb dropped on uh Hiroshima
was 15 Kil so the one that crashed was
1400 kilotons I thought half a Megaton
or something it didn't detonate all
right but it contaminated the
area so after this crash um so Denmark
and the US they try to they're like look
it was just an accident we didn't we
didn't mean it sorry we've been flying
all of these [__] H Bombs over your
airspace even we told you that we
weren't uh so there was that so the
Danes were a little pissed about that
but they said okay well we're going to
like talk to you about it so how do you
want to deal with this
situation now the US says well let's
just let the [__] like sink into the
Fjord and just stay there cuz that would
that's the easiest solution obviously
and we're lazy and that's just what we
would do um the Danes were like oh no
that that's not what's going to happen
you guys need to come here and get all
of this [__] wreckage um and all of
the ice that's been contaminated by the
radioactivity and get this the [__] out
of out of our country that's what they
said um so finally the US had a cave
because they wanted that strategic
Advantage like from that Air Force Base
that they had there so they're like okay
so they had to cave in and like you know
concede to their
demands uh this cleanup was code named
crusted ice I love that name um so
basically what would happen was that if
they let it go too long um there would
be uh you know when spring came you know
the ice in the Fjord would melt and so
any debris that was left from the crash
would sink farther into the seafloor and
it would be obviously like much harder
to get
too um so basically the US crew had to
go out there uh the temperatures were
minus 75 Dees fhe which I can't even
imagine that cold uh they said yeah the
weather was [__] awful uh wind speeds
80 m per hour damn no sunlight also lot
of wind chill uh because obviously this
is above the Arctic Circle so you know
you get like uh six months of darkness
or whatever there's like the sun's not
going to rise again until like
mid-February so good luck with that um
you know you still got a month before
the sun comes out so get out there in
the dark in the freezing cold and get
all that [__] you know what I mean
that's it's your
problem so they get a bunch of uh Airmen
out there uh they had 50 of them like
walking in lines you know what I mean
like all like that and they looked for
every single piece of wreckage no matter
how [__] small they said she like
obviously they found big pieces of
wreckage they found [__] tiny pieces
of wreckage but they just had to kind of
go in a [__] line until they found
everything um they also found uh they
had a Geer count they had Geer counters
obviously so whenever they found like
patches of ice that were obviously
radioactive they had to scoop it out and
like put it in a storage container and
like take it with them you know what I
mean uh so they did actually find I mean
fair play to them they did actually find
almost all the wreckage and scoop up
most of the contaminated ice however one
piece that they did not find um was a
secondary stage cylinder
which had uh which was uranium and
lithium deuteride which was the nuclear
fuel uh components of one of the bombs
uh they didn't find it and uh they still
don't know where it is to this day it's
sou a dare you to go find it yeah nobody
wants to find that but like I said to
their credit they did get their asses
out there in the freezing cold darkness
and find almost all of the wreckage so
good for them because the Danes were not
having it they're like look [__] is
you flew this plane with four h Bombs
over our airspace after we specifically
told you not to and it crashed and you
contaminated our [__] you got to clean
that [__] up so the US were like okay
our bad so they did it they did it so
you know what I mean except for that one
piece which they never found they still
know where it is I dare you to find that
piece as far as I know I dare you to
find that piece try to make a weapon out
of that piece you're not going to be
able to do it so that's why they let it
go yeah they're like um you know yeah
Zan said THU is the most northern
location on ancient Viking maps okay
yeah see I didn't think there was
anything that's there where the [__]
King of the ice giants is living yeah
yeah yeah yeah I mean Viking hell right
well that's why I think that there was
nothing I know that you know mustach man
and all them they had a whole thing
about that um they were real into all
that Norse mythology and everything like
that but it's just kind of like so I
think a lot of those words have been
like tainted because of their
Association but it's just like it
doesn't have anything to do with
mustache man
mustache man of the Germans of the B
cross I'm trying to say that say it that
way because I don't want to get [__]
demonetized uh they they looked up to
all that Viking culture because they
they wanted to [__] get rid of this
damn what they considered like a ger
they considered it a modern Christian
Germanic Christian eminy they wanted to
get rid of that that [__] was too AFF
feminine oh no yeah they like be like
girls we yeah they suck they didn't want
they they thought a they thought
Christianity was a
feminine and they wanted to go back to
what they considered to be uh their
original dramatic religion which was uh
you know couldn't wouldn't have been the
Roman religions Christianity was one of
the Roman religions so they wanted to go
back to uh like Norse type
religions even though if you look at the
details of the Norse religions
they're kind of copying Christianity in
uh in a
way uh even the alphabet was kind of a
copy of the Roman
alphabet but uh yeah somebody was
talking about
real let me go ahead and look in the
comment
section where'd he go oh yeah it's
planting seeds he said yeah
uh did the did the thrill did the th
Society also have a hand in vill
technology V
technology all right there was
a there's a really good [__] movie
there's a really good B movie [__]
with uh uh uh what's his name
[__] booy's son called [__] Nazis
at the center of the earth what was his
name Asylum Asylum pictur yeah I think
aent made that if you go see that movie
I love that I love that movie it's great
it's a great movie I got it on Blu-ray
it's super fun it's one of the best it
was one of the best Asylum films you can
get it's called Nazis at the center of
the earth yep and that [__] is a
Straight Up documentary it's [__]
true all right well whoever wrote that
like they knew their [__] they knew
their [__] they
knew Nazi science fiction yeah okay
which is ripe for movies I don't I don't
really know why more people haven't made
movies out of that the Germans of the
the Germans of the bat cross were
imaginative okay and they they sure they
came up with all kind of crazy stuff and
they had their own history and uh they
had their own [__] science fiction
and really science fiction not only uh
uh influenced German national
socialism it also influenced Uh Russian
communism okay basically like something
out of Science Fiction it was something
futuristic real technology would came
from a [__] book that the Germans
read a long time ago it was it was late
1800s called vill the coming race yeah
they're talking about V technology or
could be vill the coming power and it
was about a bunch of
subterranean people kind of like some
something like Journey to the Center of
the Earth or some of these [__] froan
watching froan [__] yeah forian
forian s you know they thought there
were these [__] um in in the book
there were sub a Subterranean race of
people and they used a technology that
was based on
Vil vill was kind of like Chi or the
force that's what they're talking yeah
and uh I think I think some of the
people that were like fans of friederick
nii and the idea of the will MH which is
the will is true uh in my in my
experience if [__] I'm I'm uh I'm I'm
an admirer of of of friedrick
nii and the concept of the
will which is kind of like where the
force came from and its dark side that
that that's George Lucas's [__] okay
actually he got that from his teacher
down in UCLA his name was Joseph
Campbell and uh well Joseph Campbell is
very famous Joseph Campbell if you read
there's some really good books that he
read and from that he came up with the
idea of the forest out of Star Wars okay
and Frederick nii and another guy named
Arthur scoph Hower or
schopenhauer depends on how you want to
pronounce I heard scopen Hower but some
say shopen hour those two actually kind
of outly the the force and the dark side
side and they got it
from
Buddhism
okay uh this is European
Buddhism one of the things that V
talking about V Tech one of the things
we did a show about that a while back
yeah yeah we did a show about that back
a long time ago it's a very complicated
subject it is yeah but coming out of
dramatic science
fiction was concept of v and then later
there was Legends of the Nazis making
things called V saucers yeah which is a
flying saucer powered by V yeah it
didn't happen no it didn't happen it
didn't happen it's just some guys wanted
to hoax some books and they were working
on things that were kind of like f fly
SAU with vertical landing and
takeoff uh aircraft that would be kind
of like the damn [__] what was that
thing called it would look like a rocket
it landed on its tail and it had Ram
Jets on the end of the [__] I forgot
what that [__] thing is called D says
the Bell uh yeah yeah we talked about
that the we talked about the Bell there
probably wasn't a bell that
that's did we I don't know if we did a
whole show about that we might have
talked about that on the real show which
was one of our very very early issues
that story started to come from people
after the
war it sounds cool though it sounds cool
but that probably didn't happen if there
was a
bell they talked about something that
had to do with Mercury and it glowed
blue and it killed
people that's a description of an ion
Engine with an ion engine you need
Mercury it does kind of glow
blue it might be dangerous but I think
that the Mythos was written
about written around the knowledge of a
[__] ion engine sure uh satellites do
have I some of them do have ion engines
to keep them in orbit it's a very low
thrust it's better in space because it
takes a lot of time to get up to [__]
velocity yeah it's true the Germans of
the B cross did want [__] exotic
propulsion they wanted things that
didn't involve moving Parts because that
that's expensive to
make they would be interested in in
something like an ion engine and yeah
there is theoretically the possibility
where they might have made some kind of
ion engine experiments but it it would
have required so much electricity and
the thrust would have been extremely
low it wouldn't have worked not back in
those days well and not for their
purposes yeah what they wanted you're
not going to make a goddamn jet engine
or anything that would challenge even a
propeller engine it would have been too
expensive to do the r& too expensive it
would have been big too big an ay and it
wouldn't have produced enough propulsion
enough thrust
I could see where they were going with
that but a regular internal combustion
engine with propeller on the front of it
would be cheaper and far more efficient
and more powerful than any any ion
engine in in an
atmosphere like the Earth you know but I
think the stories of the Bell were kind
of made to sound like the Germans were
trying to figure out an ion engine well
like you said said when when we talked
about the show the show we did a long
time ago about vill and all that like
you know Germans of the bent cross and
the Occult cuz they were super into that
[__] um and that's fascinating yeah they
really thought there was some kind of
like weird paranormal Supernatural
aspect to their belief system where they
thought that they could kind of like
maybe approach things from a
supernatural point of view or they were
coming at things from or were they
trying to
scientifically prove some paranormal
[__] because I know there's a lot of
crossover yeah there's cross at that
time period because of the spiritualism
movement and all German philosophy was
is to make things round and fluid and
naturalistic like the Volkswagen Bug
very kind of actually round and [__]
naturalistic everything was nature
oriented people don't realize that the
Germans of the bent cross were
nudists okay they were very much nature
or oriented there was a lot of things
about them that actually almost kind of
paralleled hippies all right a little
bit they were they were like that okay
um they were uh take pictures of
themselves nude and they had fun and
they sexuality was open from their point
of view although it was heterosexual
although it had a homosexual root to
those guys like Ern Rome and the SS and
the sa excuse me Were Gay it was a gay
army gay leather daddies Ernst was
[__] openly gay and he [__] really
kind of
helped put we're talking about Nazis now
okay yeah well you know how you yeah
yeah um but what I was getting at is
that the Germans thought that their best
designers if you want to call them best
or designers their best thinkers were
saying that machines should be more
rounded and aerodynamic and more like
things that you would see in nature and
they were working at that even this
included propulsion and in a way jet
propulsion was kind of more like
something you'd see in nature that's
what you have coming out of a damn
octopus where it sucks something in
through the front squirts it out the
back and they right like I said I get
where people get it's not dumb like
people they're looking at nature and
they're seeing that most machines in
that era were [__] square and and
[__] blocky they weren't aerodynamic
or spelt you know rounded the Germans
were trying to go that way
they were right but like I said I I get
that I get some of the extreme crazies
thought that there was an underlying
energy kind of like the will called the
vill vill like something that they read
out of a damn science fiction book yeah
that you could use that to power see
that's an aircraft and or something but
that never went anywhere that was just
[__] on paper you know yeah and some
designers a lot of that was hypothetical
hypothetical hypothetical hypothetical
wishful thinking more than anything else
yeah I think they did want that some of
them really did believe in that but yeah
Zan said the book was called the coming
race Madam blotsky had a big part in all
that yeah we I think we've talked about
her several times we talked about her on
the real show we've talked about her in
some other shows too she comes up a lot
um in anytime you talk about
spiritualism or any weird uh
spiritualist movements from that from
the early 20th century her name's gonna
come up the Germans of the BET cross and
Uncle Addie and [__] like that they were
into um paranormal oh yeah I thought
there was something to that M uh but so
was a so were a lot of other people a
lot of people it was very much in the Z
it was that time of even in the United
States they thought that I am fascinated
with that time period though like I love
that kind of like I said I'm really into
the whole idea particularly in the
United States because was huge like
spiritualism movement like in the early
um 20th century and all of the seances
and all of the um mediums and stuff like
that I love all that kind of stuff it's
it's just like I don't think any of it's
real obviously I think all of it was
[__] but um and I love all the stuff
about like Houdini trying to like
[__] uh you know go to the seances
trying to figure out how they were doing
it and [__] like that it's like I love
that kind of [__] I love that [__] now
we've had Germans on who were regulars
on the show that have disappeared
because one time I said something bad I
guess they I guess I said something bad
about the Germans I don't say anything
bad about the Germans
um the Germans of the bent cross were a
natural result they were reaction to
what was happening in Russia with the
Communists every action has an equal and
opposite reaction well the thing about
it is that you can't I would never
blame all of the Germans for that [__]
right yeah one it was a long time ago
two even a lot of Germans at the time
were like [__] yeah and some of them or
they didn't know what was going on most
of them didn't know what was going on
you know what I mean it's just that uh
the Soviet Union at that time was a huge
threat there was a German version of
Communism known as German national
socialism it ended up killing a lot of
their enemies which those enemies ended
up being big players in the United
States and we get the stories that we're
going to get uh did they do good
nah but neither of them did out of those
two they were both evil out of those two
evils I'd say the Russians were worse
they killed more Jews and more innocent
people and more of their own people than
the Germans ever even thought of I mean
it's all bad they're all bad it's not
the misery Olympics it's all bad yeah it
was all bad out of the in terms of just
sheer numbers the Russians and the and
the Soviets at that time were [__]
far worse than the Germans they were
more Insidious and they killed a lot
more people and they killed their own
people at least the Germans thought they
were killing their enemies when they did
what they did the Germans would the
Russians would kill loyal Russian
citizens just to fill numbers just to
fill quotas they were cold blooded very
cold blooded go the rest uh Zan said
that you were talking about the trf
flugal trug yeah trial the tri Fugal
vertical takeoff jet yeah that was a a
vertical landing and takeoff aircraft it
was way ahead of his time and it would
have worked but you didn't need it mean
they can do that now but you can do it
now but helicopter's better back then
they couldn't do I'm G to get another
drink all right yeah yeah yeah so here's
a Kind of a Funny Story and Tom told me
that there was another one that happened
like more recently and apparently this
happens more often than I'm aware of
Pilots rejecting from their plane and
the plane just keeps on flying which is
very funny to me but this one happened
in
1970 so this guy who was a first
lieutenant Gary faou was his name so
he's doing a test flight in 1970 he's in
his fighter jet all of a sudden his his
fighter jet for whatever reason goes
into a flat spin which uh apparently
seems
uncontrollable now so he's trying to get
his [__] together he's trying to you
know get control back over it um the
plane by the way was an uh f106
Interceptor oh yeah uh so he tries to
get control over it um but he's like
okay I can't do this [__] it's just it's
freaking out so he's just like okay I'm
ejecting so he ejected he was 8,000 ft
uh off the ground so he ejected and
safely landed
thankfully now the weird thing about it
was though was that once he ejected you
know he Glides safely to the ground and
he looks toward the plane thinking that
the plane's going to crash because it
was spinning and it was just doing all
kind of [__] and he's just like man I
ejected so obviously something bad was
happening but
the plane kept on
going it just it came out of the spin
apparently on its own and just kept on
flying um as though someone was in it so
he was just like huh look at that it's a
little crazy I love this one of his
wingmen uh whose name was Major Jim low
he yells over the radio
reportedly Gary you better get back in
it and I'm just like
I'm not really sure how you expect that
to happen like what you want to jump up
in the air and get back in the plane or
I think he was on the ground at this
point I'm you know I'm not really
sure even if he was on the ground at
that point or if he was coming down to
the parachute hey get back in the plane
yeah I don't think that's going to
happen major I I just don't think that's
going to happen get back in the plane
Gary no I'm not getting back in the
plane so he's just watching the plane
and the
plane flies along for a little while and
then
lands perfectly fine in a wheat field
which has snow on it it's just like it
just comes to a [__] land and he's
like I'll be [__] damned I mean can
you imagine he thought it was going to
[__] crash right so he just dumps out
of it you know uh so the cops come and
the plan's engine when the cops got
there was still
running so uh they're just like well we
don't really know what's going on with
this um so we're just going to let it
sit here and run until it runs out of
fuel you know so they don't want it to
blow up or anything like that so it's
just kind of like they just kind of sat
there and waited and it was fine so they
let it kind of you know work itself out
and then they took it and they brought
it back to the Air Force thing and um
they fixed it and the plane went back
into active surface they still have no
IDE as far as I know they still have no
idea what caused it to go into a flat
spin like that they don't really have
any idea what caused that [__] [__]
but can you imagine thinking that your
plane's going to crash like I said going
into a flat spin like that and being
like and being so bad that an
experienced pilot be like [__] this [__]
I got to get out of here and then like
landing on the ground and then watching
the plane just sailing on without you
and then Landing very casually in a
field yeah landed yeah it was fine they
used it again okay they put it back into
service I missed the part of it yeah so
the landing gear were down was down what
[__] know I guess I don't really know it
went into a flat spin well there was
snow on the ground okay so but they said
it landed just fine it wasn't damaged or
anything like that as far as I know and
it's just like it just kind of landed
there and he's just like what the [__]
there's this he's just like watching it
like cuz he jumped out with the
parachute he thought it was gonna
[__] blow up or crash or something
[__] like that how did it stop don't
know I guess it just [__]
okay all right crazy but he just thought
it was crazy because he ejected and then
like he's like so I watched it and then
it just was normal it r at itself like
flying as though someone was flying it
yeah and he's just like what the [__] is
going
on which is crazy that's
crazy all right so now we're going to
talk about uh a similar thing that
happened that um didn't work out so well
I hate to tell you and this was a Soviet
era thing this happened in 1989 that
last one uh I think I mentioned it but
it happened last one happened in 1970
these are all in chronological order
like I said so this is the Belgian Mig
23 Crash from
1989 so um so July 4th 1989 you have a
colonel uh Nikolai skiden I think is how
you pronounce his last name um he had
just come back from vacation and he was
going on a routine like training Mission
like an inter intercept training Mission
over the Baltic
Sea so he was going to leave from this
one uh air base in Poland which I cannot
even begin to pronounce and when he took
off it's like everything seemed fine at
first but when he got to about 150 M and
put up his landing gear he saw that the
plane um the After Burner had
failed so he sees all this smoke coming
out of the back of the plane and the
plane started to lose power like
significantly so he radios back to base
he's like I'm look this is bad I'm going
to eject so the um you know the higher
up said yeah you totally should eject so
he did now he ejected from the
jet now apparently without the dude in
the plane and the ejection seat which
how much can that weigh not really much
but after he got out the plane did not
crash it pitched up and Rose up into the
air as though it was taking off as
though someone was in it uh the engine
was still
running at this point it leaves polish
airspace and then goes into East Germany
and then into West Germany it's just
flying on its own what year was this
again uh 19 when was this 1989
1989 so so yeah so the plane goes into
East Germany then into West Germany uh
at the point that it comes into this
area uh the European uh US Air Force is
just kind of like what the [__] is going
on with that yeah so it's like we need
to do something about that so I'm not
sure at this point if they knew that the
plane was
unmanned you know what I mean yeah um
but they're like okay okay well this
could have hostile intentions obviously
because it's in their airspace so they
send two F-15 Eagles uh from the 32nd
tactical figh Fighter Squadron um who
had been based out of the cerber air
base in the Netherlands so they take off
to intercept this
plane now they're watching this plane
this plane is only going 400 knots
relatively slow and they didn't really
see any signs of any nuclear weapons on
board like I said I'm not sure at this
point if they were sure that it was on
manned or not so they said okay well
don't shoot it down yet just follow it
so they're going to let it continue its
flight and see what happens they're kind
of hoping that it's going to maybe crash
into the water like the English Channel
or something like
that so they keep following it it goes
over Dutch airspace and then it goes
into Belgian
airspace now at this point they're like
okay well we had thought that we weren't
going to shoot this [__] thing down
but at this point they're like you know
it could you know considering the
trajectory that it's on they're like it
could crash into um Le I guess is how
you pronounce it the French city so like
obviously we don't want that to happen
so like we're going to wait till it's
over the North Sea and then we're going
to shoot it
down um but they soon determined that
the jet was running out of fuel
so they call the French Air Force and
they're like you know what do you guys
want to do about this uh because the
plane was making a turn toward the
South what ended up happening sadly was
that the plane had flown on its own for
about 600 miles over several countries
airspaces uh you know cu the guy had
jumped out of it because he thought it
was going to
crash it ended up crashing into a farm
in
Belgium uh sadly there was one person in
that Farmhouse a 19-year-old student
named Vim deir deir I think is how you
pronounce his last name I'm sorry if I'm
Mis mispronouncing it uh he was actually
asleep in the house um he had just
finished his University
exams uh and he was sleeping in the
house and unfortunately the plane which
was unmanned crashed into the house and
killed him um other people did live in
the house including that dude's dad uh
and several other family members but
they were not home at the time like his
dad was at work and his other family
members were out like running errands or
whatever so sadly he was the only one in
there he was only 19 years old and he
got killed when this plane crashed into
the
[__] now um so the at that time General
Secretary of the Communist party uh who
was Mel
gorov uh he told the media he was sorry
about what happened which you know
that's the least you can do do really
but basically the Belgian authorities
were very concerned at how long it had
taken for Soviet officials to tell
Belgium about the fact that there was an
unmanned aircraft flying around in their
airspace that might potentially crash
into their [__] which is what ended up
happening also um Belgium were afraid
that it might have nuclear weapons on it
which thankfully it did not but they
didn't know that so they were just kind
of like yeah um thanks for the apology
but could have told us about some [__]
before the [__] crashed and killed a
person so you know so there was like a
lot of [__] about that then but yeah
that's actually kind of a long shot that
it hits the ground and kills somebody
yeah well like I said that was very
usually like I said it usually just hits
the ground or it hits like the water or
something like that because yeah there's
a lot of people around but statistically
speaking people constitute like a small
meteors hit the ground all the time they
do and they never really hit anything
they never really hit anything every now
and then you hear a crazy story about
like a meteor crashing through
somebody's roof and like hitting them
when they were on the couch cuz I have
heard one story about that yeah most of
them land out in the ocean but most of
them land in the ocean or like in some
empty field or something like that
because like most people live in kind of
you know higher density areas and we
live in Florida we could be [__]
sleeping in bed and then out of the blue
out of nowhere we fall into a sinkhole
the sink holes are just you know what I
worry about that I worry about falling
into a sinkhole or getting by lightning
yeah or getting eaten by an alligator
sink holes have happened they just open
up the whole [__] house and the whole
neighborhood Falls in there right it
happens all the time well especially
like um if you go through a period where
it doesn't rain that much cuz Florida is
right on um sea is right at sea level
and underneath like if you dig down
Florida it's just sand yeah so it's like
there's no if um you know if you have a
drought for a long time it's like
there's no water under there nothing
like that and so like the ground will
start to collapse so I remember when I
was growing up there would often be
cases sometimes not that far away from
me where like a whole like whole bunch
of houses would just like fall into a
hole like suddenly there was one a
couple years back me and Jim were
thinking about it where a guy was just
sleeping in bed and out of the blue
while he was asleep
[__] that room and the whole fuing
bed and everything went down the se he
made it though he got he lived yeah went
down into the ground imagine that you're
sleeping and you're like what the [__]
like I said I have nightmares about that
the [__] earth like I said the Earth
is sweat is [__] swallowing you up
right and that's not crazy that could
happen it happens all the time in
Florida so it's just kind of like like I
said I'm more worried about Florida
specific [__] sink holes cuz that
happens all the time getting eaten by
alligators yeah that could happen
hurricane get yeah um getting struck by
light getting killed by a tornado killed
by a hurricane um you know well
hurricane also causes tornadoes so
there's that too so you know you get
your whole [__] [__] Florida man down
yeah you get kill you might get your
face eaten off by Florida man you
Florida man could just appear yeah you
never know man yeah Florida man he does
all kind of crazy things so yeah um it's
a dangerous place to live no I don't
think it's as dangerous as Australia at
least they have like great white sharks
and poisonous snakes well we have
poisonous snakes too but not as many as
Australia so that's another thing you
got to wash out for I'm not even worried
about snakes I don't worry about snakes
though but they don't kill that many
people but we do have several um several
species of venomous coral snakes not
poisonous venomous coral snakes usually
don't kill anybody coral snakes
rattlesnakes water moccasins what's the
other one there's another
one I don't think there's four there's
four S water no no water moccasin water
moccasins God everybody every Florida
kid has this drilled into them and now I
can't remember because I'm kind of in
coral snakes here but I don't think
anybody's everever really died of a
coral snake well because in Florida
everybody knows that [__] well most
people that get bit were either trying
to [__] with the snake like trying to
catch it yeah trying to kill it or um
they were like oh I was doing yard work
and I reached into the bushes and there
happened to be one in there and it B me
you know what I mean so you do kind of
see that happen what an case but it's
not very common and you don't usually
die because usually you can get to the
hospital and they have antien in because
it's Florida we know about that [__]
what's the fourth one I don't remember
now I can't remember oh we also have
venomous spiders yeah black um Black
Widow and brown Reco we have those too
my brother got bit by a brown recluse on
his knee back in the
90s and he got blood poisoning like it
went he had to walk with a cane for a
while it went like all the way up his
leg like that you could see the poison
like going up his leg it was [__]
freaky okay so these last two were kind
of funny nobody
died so the British
accidentally as as one does invaded
Spain in 2002 so what happened so there
were two dozen British Marines and they
were on a training exercise in
2002 and as part of this training
exercise they stormed a
beach now the beach that they stormed
they thought was in jalter which I guess
was the you know uh accepted place that
they were supposed to do the exercise
at as it turned out though the place
that they stormed was not jalter it was
actually a beach in La lanaa Spain which
was a resort so here's all these British
Marines storming the beach and
everybody's just like what the [__] are
you doing here um so they come up on the
beach and then a couple of locals that
were on the beach each and a couple of
cops were like um what are you doing
here like you know what I mean so there
was that now what they said here was
their excuse later on they said oh the
weather was really bad um and we
couldn't really see where we were
which okay that maybe it was I don't
know um Spanish officials were pretty
cool about it they're just like all
right just let's not let it happen again
you know what I mean um but they did I
love this the Spanish uh gave the
British a very very sarcastic um they're
like yeah it's cool and everything but
you know you should have been able to
see jalter no jalter because it has this
1,400 foot tall rock that is like right
there so you should have
known that that was the place that you
were going instead of this place which
does not have a, 1400t Rock so you know
just saying just say so we a little
passive aggressive about it and I kind
of love that um now this is apparently
not the only time that this is has
happened that a country has accidentally
invaded another country I'm sure it
probably happens all the time um
apparently Switzerland has also invaded
lonstein accidentally three times Well
it's not it's not like they're
enemies yeah they're just coming into
their [__] like with their army and
stuff like that um and one time the
Swiss soldiers actually caused a big
forest fire there so lonstein were not
too happy about that but like I said it
does kind of happen from time to time
nobody knows where like the [__]
exact country L is I guess so it's just
kind of like easy to happen so here's
one that you should appreciate Tom
because this is very recent and you can
go off on a rant about how nobody's as
cool as they used to be back in your
day like you do like old man yelling a
cloud yeah like they [__] Su well
this one no no there were people back in
the past that were [__] awesome
recently they're [__] suck like well
and like I said but there were people
back in the past who were idiots also as
we have talked about on this show yeah
every like people can make mistakes at
any time I'm just saying all right this
one happened actually this was a while
back so this was in
2010 so these were a couple of
helicopter pilots in
2010 now they were from the helicopter
Maritime strike Squadron
41 so they're flying some um mh6
helicopters over Lake Tahoe for whatever
reason I'm not really sure what the
whole mission was so everything fine
they're branch is this um I don't know
okay all right they Mari time it's got
to be
[__] Navy or Coast Guard I would
imagine yeah okay so they're doing their
[__] and then suddenly Witnesses who are
a lake to because it's Lake Hao there's
like you know a lot of tourists and
stuff like that so they see one of the
helicopters kind of dip down into the
water and um dip down into the water
like dip down into the water kind of
like like that okay and so a bunch of
and you know obviously this is 2010 so
everybody has cell phones so it's like
some people are like what the [__]
going on so they film it you know what I
mean so a lot bunch of people got in a
video so like what's going on do they
have some kind of like engine problem or
were they trying to like pretend they
were doing a search and rescue mission
or what's going on okay so they found
out later the answer was um that what
they were doing was that the pilot this
was a $33 million helicopter by the way
so he wanted to go super low over the
water because he wanted a super cool
profile picture for the squad's Facebook
page so he
was he was trying to get like a really
good background yeah yeah um okay to to
do that all right um now so what
happened was that the pilots of the
helicopters um reportedly took their
hands off the controls so they could
take pictures of each other yeah flying
the helicopter okay yeah um and then
they're tripping so yeah so then because
nobody had their hands on the controls
like one of the so the so the helicopter
starts kind of plummeting toward the
water as as it does when no one is
controlling it um just Pro tip and So
eventually like I said thankfully no one
died or anything like that but it's like
the pilot was like oh holy [__] and he
goes over back there and kind of gets
control back of it and he gets up out of
the water however of the damage to the
helicopter ended up costing costing
$500,000 because a bunch of the like
antenna and [__] like that were all
[__] up because they dipped down into
the water yeah um so these two idiots
got back to base and they lost their
flight status um as far as I know that
[__] around that's all yeah well you
know that's kind of what you do officers
man officers are [__] up yeah the
thing with social media man don't try to
get like cool pictur CU here's the thing
this I don't know why I just thought of
this but you know how people try to get
like super cool pictures for uh for
Instagram or whatever or Tik Tok or
whatever and then they like they're like
hey look at me I'm like on the edge of a
cliff and then they fall off the cliff
and die yeah this is kind of like a
situation like that but thankfully
nobody died yeah cuz you're trying to
get a cool picture yeah but please don't
go to the edge of or look at me I'm like
right next to like a [__] um you know
Panther all right and then it eats you
so although I've seen [__] people
that own those things and they're
[__] wonderful living in the
house Panthers yeah we know mountain
lions yeah well we they can be if you
raise them they
they any other cat pet cats yeah are
genetically not really any different
from wild cats yeah so if you raise them
and I'm not saying don't please don't
raise wild cats in your house unless you
have a permit but I'm just saying that
Florida we got them they do have them
here people do raise them but if you
raise them from a kitten yeah um you
shouldn't have a problem because they do
behave exactly the way house cat behaves
yeah well like I said genetically
they're not any different there's a
channel on YouTube called I am Puma it's
a Russian couple and he they have
several cats and one of them is a dam
his name is Messi and he's a American
Mountain Li and he just loves [__]
that man that owns him just loves him
he's just like and his wife is like
daddy's coming home daddy's coming he's
just waiting for Daddy to come home he's
a big ass [__] Mountain Li gets in
bed with him [__] you know he's just
kissing on the [__] big cat's face
and [__] and it it is cute it's super
cute that but be like well that thing
will eat you no I mean probably not no I
I can I can gets mad one day you know
I'm part of my side gig was being animal
trainer my mother was a [__] famous
horse trainer in Califor she's a very
wellknown horse very well known and
she's been in newspapers and magazines
and everything and I came up around all
different kinds of big
animals and uh [__] I know cats and
cat behavior but animal body language
you can tell when an animal love
somebody they they won't hurt you you
know but the thing is is with that thing
hurt somebody else maybe see that's kind
of more what I would be worried about
like that some friend would come over
and they'd be like yeah I don't like
this person like pop you know cuz like I
said if we had people over and our cats
didn't like that person they're too
little to do anything to that person
they could just like scratch them or
bite them or something they couldn't
like knock their head off or bite their
face off but in general they're a good
character all big cats a good character
and here's something that you should uh
chew on for a while because I think the
United States really should kind of lack
some of its laws about big cats as
pets Romans ancient Romans kept lions
and big Pets the rich people kept him in
in their house they were they didn't
report anything matter of fact when they
put him into the damn Arena as like
gladiatorial combatants they weren't
very good combatants they tended to
cower and run and the the crowd would
boo them you know like yeah this don't
kill those things because cats are not
normally they're not Fighters they're
they just want to eat you know and they
grab little things and try to eat them
you got to force a cat to
fight kind of cruel yeah that's not
really their nature yeah it's not really
in their nature uh but
uh the problem is is that uh if you look
at the world and human encroachment into
the
habitats especially in
Africa where are those cats going to
live that the uh a human encro
is [__] [__] up their habitat do
you want them to all go
extinct uh the best choice for the
species of those big cats is to live in
a symbiotic fashion with human beings
the way the dogs on the other cat I mean
if we're going to take up all the room
then we they should move into the house
with you people are like well damn I
mean you better they better take some
you better take some responsibility take
some responsib you're taking their human
that's really where the big cat should
be they should be in homes the way dogs
are and yeah they're big you got to feed
them but if you take one in your house
you you better have the money and we got
and you people might be sing like you're
[__] crazy there's a dude that just
lives a few miles from here that has a
whole [__] Farm filled with he has a
whole compound yeah right with a big
cement wall around it yeah and he sells
them how many miles not it like five
miles about 5 miles from here he s five
miles from here but you got to have a
license to have one well yeah you can't
just have them most of his clients are
he has other animals too not just B cats
he has giraffes and [__] yeah he has
giraffes and stuff yeah but yeah he has
like a whole compound yeah he's he he's
he's like he's like Tiger King he's like
Tiger King but he's pretty famous not
yeah I think wasn't he a uh I think he
was one of the damn Tarzan I think he
might have been yeah I think you're
right yeah he might have been I think he
he not John not Johnny weisser no but he
he's an old man now Johnny weisser's got
to be dead by now right I would think
that was a long time ago yeah Zan said
Mig 23 is well known for being a piece
of [__] aircraft so this isn't
surprising yeah I've heard that as well
uh Zan said also that you can survive a
lightning strike which some people have
and they've even had like hey I can now
play the piano or I can do super math
and stuff like that which is crazy if I
got struck by lightning it would
probably just make you [__] yeah
which probably just make me [__] I
wouldn't I wouldn't get that lucky yeah
um said I don't think you can survive a
sinkhole some people do though some
people do yeah head dude survive s he
went down about 30 feet into the ground
with his bed he was in his bed yeah
technically you could because if the
hole was big enough and you were in your
bed and you had something to like cush
in your fall then you probably could and
they could get you out you know what I
mean but it's just like that would be
[__] Terri that was the one about
seven eight years ago I think yeah uh
his whole it happens a lot like in
Florida though it it wasn't the whole
house it was his bedroom yeah and he was
in it but I've seen it where it happened
like I don't know about a whole
neighborhood but I've seen like several
houses like four or five houses like in
one like thing like go I remember seeing
the helicopter shot of that house part
of it was down in that SLE it's
terrifying like I said so that could
happen in Florida yeah when when you're
least expecting it if if you didn't need
something else to worry about he was
very lucky like you might just fall in a
hole randomly that's some like you know
it's not just that it's like oh I went
outside and there was an alligator in my
pool and he ate me but or he bit my leg
off or whatever but it's like you might
just fall in a hole Yeah it happens um
Zan said I used to worry about black
widows being in the desert but I see
them all the time they don't ever bother
anyone never heard of someone getting
bitten by them by one I've never heard
of anybody being bitten by a black widow
like I said my brother got bitten by a
brown reck but that wasn't in a house
that was outside like he was out in the
woods like you know what I mean like out
at on a nature trail or whatever and he
got bitten in the knee but he didn't
know by a brown recluse um black widows
I've seen them around but I've seen a
bunch of them just like most animals
they won't [__] with you unless you [__]
with them but the spider but the thing
about it is that sometimes you [__] with
them without meaning to you know what I
mean it's like sometimes they're in your
house and like you reach a hand and
somewhere and it's in there or you're
outside like I said um people that get
bitten by snakes in FLA Florida usually
they're trying to catch them they're
trying to catch them or they're doing
gardening and they don't know that the
snake is there so it's like oh I stick
my hand in the bush and then there's a
snake in there and they didn't most
snakes like Rattlers and [__] will warn
you yeah they don't want to which is
nice of them I think well Venom is has a
lot of caloric yeah they don't want to
use it they don't want to use it up just
on any random other [__] they just is
like look I'm I'm gonna bite you yeah
you keep [__] with me right but yeah
they don't want to use want you to let
them leave them alone right and
generally as long as you leave animals
alone yeah snakes and stuff like that
they will not bite you but like I said
it does happen accidentally sometimes
does happen
accidentally um Dan said you could
invade lickstein by going for a walk
through the park that country is so
small yeah yeah I mean so you could see
like Switzerland is just kind of like oh
oopsie do we invade your country again
I'm I'm terribly sorry about that um Zan
also says crashing a helicopter for a
profile picture is totally dude logic
yeah that's what I thought too I was
like that is the maybe the doest thing
that I've ever heard of don't don't
overestimate officers commissioned
officers man they're like civilians and
they just give them a [__] suit they
give them a military suit doesn't really
mean
anything uh you just have to have a
college degree to become an officer and
say I want to be an officer they when I
was in service even back back in the 90s
in the early 90 early to mid 90s they
were just getting kicked out like
[__] crazy our platoon leaders only
lasted on average about three or four
months before they were kicked out they
sucked most of them now when you get up
to SEC first lieutenant and Captain
they're better but second lieutenants
they're damond [__] dozen it's like a
private and they don't go through basic
training as you know it and they have
their own versions of it they're not
tough
though you don't need them to fight
they're paperwork dudes well they're
kind a lot of it is probably like the
corporate um equivalent of like middle
management yeah nobody needs those dudes
yeah the dudes the dudes that you really
need are kind of like the middle ranking
officers between like first
lieutenant and colonal those are really
the best guys some of the some of the
generals are good when you get up to
[__] Pentagon generals then you're
back into [__] bags they [__]
suck they're just corporate well the
farther that you get from they may as
well be running [__] McDonald's
Corporation they're not military men not
really the farther you get from like the
actual on the ground experience right
right so I don't want to dispers you
know disparage all officers they do have
some good ones uh but they got to be in
there for a while but like I said I
think that's the same issue field grades
yeah that's the same issue you run into
in corporate jobs
the remov from actuals to
get the less useful they are and I'm not
talking out my ass because a dude I went
to basic training with named [__]
private
traany okay later on when he made
[__] Spec 4 went green to gold and
end up being an armored officer he's a
friend of mine I still talk to him on
[__] Facebook and Manel pad like that
and he was an armored officer I think it
was I think it was
armor and uh told me all about how
[__] up the officer core was he was
good though green to Gold [__] those
dudes tend to be [__] good and chief
warrant officers very good all right
those are the dudes who are they're not
officers they're basically enlisted guys
who fly helicopters in the Army that's
all they do is fly helicopters or
operate heavy equipment nobody can tell
them what to what to do cuz officers
don't know what they they're a
specialist they do just that and they
and the whole idea of a warrant officer
was that they did not want any enlisted
or officer ranks [__] with them
because they just do what they do they
have their own
specialty warant officers are the
[__] they tend to be helicopter
Pilots CU they had problems back in
Vietnam and [__] where they'd have a
[__] high ranking [__] officer
tell a [__] Chopper pilot to do
something that was impossible and he
tried to do it and die okay kill
everybody you wanted a certain class
inside the military ranks that didn't
listen to officers like [__] you you
know what you're talking about well
here's the thing everybody that's in
charge of people doing a thing yeah
should have actually done that thing
right exactly because if you haven't
actually done that thing and you're
telling other people to do that thing
then you don't know what the [__] you're
talking about and that applies
across every single right everything
that applies across everything the
warrant officer rank was [__] awesome
because officers would go to them look
we want to do this can you do that and
he would go yeah we can do that or no we
can't do that okay then what how can we
do it then see that's the best we do it
this way yeah yeah best way to go about
like I said that applies across every
single job that has ever existed right
if somebody is in charge of a bunch of
people that are doing a thing
yeah you have to have done that thing
yeah two of my uncles are chief warrant
officer threes that's where they got out
both of them Task Force 160 Special
Operations Aviation they're
Brothers uh their last name was Frost
they're now working as helicopter pilots
and bodyguards for very rich saudy Royal
people they do a lot of time in Dubai
they live in the Middle East that's what
they do the warrant officer classes was
the way to go if you wanted to do they
make a [__] ton of and they're older
than me and they are jacked as
[__] cuz Task Force 160 and Delta and
all those guys they were all doing test
and other gear they were doing good back
in those days back in the 90s when they
were good I don't know what they're like
now probably not as good but but
yeah chief warant officer Frost both of
them they're doing well right
now zand said we have scorpions out here
but they T typically hide under rocks
I've only seen one we have scorpions
here too um I've seen them in people's
houses I've seen them in people's
garages I've seen them in people's
bathrooms under their towels yeah um
small ones like not huge or anything
like that but I have seen them here yeah
Tammy said look what happened to uh Sig
freed Andor Roy yeah yeah with the tiger
yeah I can like I said you can't there's
a big problem with so-called lion
Tamers they're taking lions that they
know that are already tame and they're
[__] [__] with them to put on a
good show that's a disaster waiting to
happen I kind of feel like if you're GNA
have a big cat yeah it's probably better
not to [__] with them yeah well TR like
put them on display or like try to get
them to do stuff that they wouldn't
normally do because that's going to um
end badly yeah so performing I'm not
really into the whole performing animal
thing yeah animals especially big cats
don't understand what a performance is
they don't understand that they're just
trying to do what Their caregivers is
telling them to do I would never put a
cat into that position it's I would not
like that you're going to confuse that
cat if you have a big cat like that then
you have to be that Cat's friend you
have to love that cat that cat has to
love you you're feeding it you're
petting it that's all they understand
that yeah I don't like the whole like
putting on perform Big Show and [__]
we're going to do this I'm going to
scare you and you're going to [__]
growl and [__] no they they just don't
they're not built for that man you they
don't fully understand what it is you're
doing and what you're making I don't
really like the whole performing animal
yeah performance is not something
animals are supposed to do because they
don't because they're like oh well okay
I can do this in this context but not in
this other context you know what I mean
and it's like I'm not really sure that
they like understand the some monkeys
like I said it's like a little kid they
don't really get some monkeys might
understand certain elements of
performance but I wouldn't not cats cats
don't know what that
is dogs might they're very social yeah
May yeah probably they're like look I'm
making them happy dogs just want to make
everybody
happy cats are not like that cats aren't
like that no they're not like that
though right they're kind of their own
yeah they're very much their own and I
guarantee you Sig freed and Roy loved
cats those two dudes loved cats they did
and those cats probably love those dudes
oh yeah they're probably real good with
them but they get very confused of what
they're asking them to do they're asking
them to growl and to put on these
[__] shows and [__] and and and
that's not what that is man that is a
African savannah Predator it's supposed
to be out on the [__] African
planes you know what I mean a big lion
here's the thing it's not it's not just
to be in a show I mean okay our cat
Pooky is super smart and she understands
a lot of things that I didn't think that
cats could understand but she still does
not understand that you can chew on some
things or Claw on some things and not on
other others right yeah so it's just
kind of like when she claws when she
starts clawing on Tom's boots yeah and
Tom yells at her she looks at him like
what the [__] yeah why not why not yeah
I can Claw on the thing on the cat tree
I can Claw on this other thing yeah and
you don't yell at me because of that why
are you yelling at me now right so she
doesn't understand the distinction cuz
it's the same behavior to her it's just
clawing yeah I'm just clawing why are
you yelling at me right yeah and like
she looks at you like what the [__] she
really does give you like that for her
she can't she doesn't yeah she can't
differentiate she doesn't understand
like like I said the context just say no
don't do that she's like what why yeah
don't not she's like I scratch on this
[__] I scratch on that [__] nobody yells
at me right I scratch on this [__] and
you yell at me it's the same behavior
and you're yelling at me so something
like a Sig freen Roy style lion show
those Lions can't really comprehend
what's happening uh it's it's not good
they don't have the brain power they
weren't built for that like I said cats
are very smart dogs are very smart yeah
um but the fact that you're punishing
them yeah for this for what they
perceive as the same behavior making
them growl and Roar and that and yeah
like making them act like that it's just
like I don't think that's a good thing
for you to be doing because they don't
understand the concept of all cats are
just chasing machines that's what their
job is to chase things and to eat it and
then when they're fed they they're if
you look at them it's all about
affection they're cats are very
affectionate to each other big cats
lions they lay on their belly digesting
they lick each other and they're hanging
out they're very
chilled
um performance is not part of their
normal life just it's just it's not
right yeah I'm not really into yeah that
whole idea making animals like that
perform for cuz I like I said I'm not
sure if they entirely understand [__]
they used to do to [__] animals and
[__] back in the early 1900s break your
heart put them into a [__] totally
bare cage look at this black panther you
know in front of people and there's
nothing for the cat to do I know that
like bums me out and like you know but
like I said they didn't understand they
didn't understand that like animals
actually are right are really
intelligent if you had a good
relationship with that cat you'd go in
there and just [__] rub on that cat
and [__] kiss him and [__] you
know grab his face and [__] and they
they they like that they like affection
just like a regular like little petat
just like anything else right yeah like
I said pet cats are not genetically any
different no really they're just animals
live in a world of feelings and emotion
that's not logic you know yeah same
thing with big horses even though
they're a they're a herd animal and it's
a different rules there there's
hierarchy and respect and disrespect
they have that too so but there's when
you're dealing with horses there's a
certain feeling I don't know I just kind
of grew up with it since a kid you know
what I mean I could I can communicate
with them like horse Whispering my
mother was a famous horse whisperer is
what they call but it's not whispering
it's body language horses understand
Lang body language and behavior and what
you do with and you understand that also
you understand it also it was just
natural and that extends across species
most species have that I mean like all
species are different they're not verbal
they can't speak yes everything is body
language you have to watch right yeah
the way their ears go the way they're
moving the way their tail goes
everything like that you have where you
position yourself in a room if you're
higher or lower if you're blocking the
exit or if you're opening the exit there
it's a lot more complicated than you
think you have to you have to P picture
yourself as a being that is can't speak
how do you communicate yeah it's through
your body and where you position your
body in the room and in the space and
what is threatening and what
isn't and you know if you don't
understand what's going on if you you
don't you don't understand words it the
rules are a little bit different about
what's threatening well see that's why I
think it's really fascinating watching
stuff like Jackson Galaxy's like cat
from hell because a lot of those people
they get a cat and it behaves really
badly yeah but why it's Behaving Badly
is because the people are approaching it
in a way that's very threatening to the
cat so it's like you can't um blame the
cat for reacting the way that it does
towards them because it's like it thinks
it's being it's that it's under attack
essentially right yeah so since we got
Pooky back in I think that was 2017 we
got her when she was tiny kitten and I
looked a lot into like cat behavior and
all this kind of stuff because I was
like well I want to be able to like
raise her in a good way and not you know
scare her or anything like that so
the way that you come at a cat um makes
a lot of difference in how they react to
you how you react to the cat is cuz I
think a lot of people think that
especially people that are like dog
people they're like they don't like cats
they like oh they're so aloof and they
don't really but cats are not aloof not
really no they're not aloof um they're
only aloof if you are yeah if you are
very interactive with the interactive
with them they will be exactly as
interactive with them as you as you are
the default friendly setting for all
cats is to lay down if you lay down next
to the cat then the cat's go oh okay
this is not a
threat they'll start coming around you
yeah standing up is kind of threatening
around a cat they don't know you because
you're big you're big right you're big
and you're ready for action but if you
just see the cat you go up and you throw
yourself on the ground next to the cat
yeah you're putting yourself on the same
level as them you're like playing with
them and it's just like they sense when
you get the [__]
mentality yeah know just remember that
they can't understand what you're saying
yeah well I mean yeah I think Pooky
understands some words she know some
words she knows her name but weed her
though yeah she we raised her from a
little bitty I mean she was Tiny she was
maybe she she was maybe six weeks old
she was sleeping in a bed with us she
was like that big yeah she was Tiny she
has human facial expressions I've never
seen another cat have that she does yeah
oh look down and she'll be in the
[__] leaning up against the wall
looking at me the eyes and the face it's
like a human yeah you you can tell
exactly what she's thinking she's like
why don't you come she's like what is it
you have to eat you know what I mean
like well you want me to come up there
just I just I just her face she's very
good at Deception also or attempted
deception you know what I mean she tries
to like fool you into thinking it's like
hey you haven't given me any meat sticks
which is one of her favoris Task Force
160 is called the night nightstalkers
yeah
nightstalkers they got a lot of cool
[__] which is that Cal K yeah they were
they were at Fort C with me so sometimes
I'd go over to my [__] a aunt's house
who was married to the to one of the
frost brothers and that's where that's
where I met my other uncle they were
uncles by
marriage but uh that was at at Fort
Campbell they tried to get me into 160
but at the time I was in first 327 Recon
platoon and I I was like I don't know if
I I should have listened to them because
they said they could get me on the right
desk to get me in there as a damn minig
Gunner on the back of a special
operation CH4 uh ch47 which is a [__]
helicopter the two rotors if you're a
civilian be a minigunner in the tail I
don't know if I would have liked it
maybe I would have I you know probably
been a pretty cool job I kind of feel
like I love flying yeah you would have
liked that I think yeah but you know
being a Recon Scout I had a certain kind
of
[__] I'm going to say Pride I was
proud of what I was doing at the time
yeah you you had kind of a thing I like
I don't know an identity right I get it
but I didn't understand how how
important or Task Force 160 was I knew
there were Special Operations but I
didn't realize how deep that [__]
went um but like I said I would have
been enlisted so I wouldn't have been
like like my uncles my uncles were
[__] you know warrant officers so
they're in a different world it would
have taken a long time to get to that I
don't know what programs I would have
had to go through yeah I mean what kind
of Hoops I'd have to jump you might have
like lived a completely different life
you don't know it'd be some MC in the
Middle East Flying some [__] saudy
executive around helicopter you never
even would have met me yeah with a bunch
of [__] submachine gun [__] down
in my [__] jaet yeah I'm just
laughing about like what zanada said
earlier about crashing a helicopter for
a profile photo dud D do that yeah um
well that's the whole basis behind the
Darwin Awards yeah is that which is I
believe 98% dudes like the people in
that book cuz uh basically it's like hey
hold my beer and watch this and then
they do some stupid [__] and then they
die Zan is asked about Zig freed and
Roid what happened to them they had a
good run we yeah 20 years but we should
probably do a show on them yeah zik fre
and Roy were these two they were Germans
weren't they oh I don't know I have to
look it up I think they were Germans or
austrians or something but they lived
here in the United States there were
these two uh gay pretty boys really that
had a damn big cat show they would
[__] tour Vegas man made a [__] fam
yeah real real real famous well people
still know their names nowaday one of
them got
eaten get eaten he got attacked he got
attacked did it kill
him wait did he die I think he died [__]
man I don't even remember one of those
things jumped down and killed him and
that was it I think he died and that was
the end of that
but it went on for a long time it's just
that you're making big cats perform and
big cats were not built by Evolution to
perform they don't know what performance
is I mean they got away like like xan
said they got did get away with it for a
long time the cats did do per and you
know you see circuses and you know lions
and tigers and stuff do perform but I'm
not really I don't know I'm not a fan of
circuses making yeah big cats elephants
anything like that making them perform
I'm not a big fan of that elephants are
smart enough to know what performance is
but they're also smart enough to know
what slavery is yeah they're not doing
what they're supposed to be doing that's
why so many of them like [__] rampage
yeah you know they'll go on a rampage
and kill a bunch of people well [__] J
Allen said he didn't die he didn't die
okay I didn't think I remember seeing
video of it happening but I don't
remember if he died or not that end doed
a show that cat got him yeah but no that
was
it
so you want to goad and shut it down um
I guess so all right yeah it's been how
long be on three hours yeah Jen said she
did not yeah yeah we've been on for a
long we've been on it's it's a nice long
show okay I mean we cover everything I
wanted to cover so that good um but yeah
so hopefully you guys enjoyed the show
this evening we did a lot of sidetracks
but you know that's what always happens
Friday we're going to come back with
another show if I'm not here we'll see I
may or may not be here I mean if you're
not here right I'll probably just do it
on my own just do it on your own yeah
and I might just get super drunk and
talk to it's not the only time that
she's done it alone she did a show she
did the show for two weeks on her own it
it was a good time yeah I was listening
to it I was over in Mississippi
listening to it live yeah in case cuz I
know some people came in later yeah um
his dad is he's not doing well not doing
real well yeah so we're kind of just
waiting to see what happens he might
have to fly to Mississippi
yeah to be with his dad yeah we see join
the Nether world of the force we'll see
how that goes It goes yeah um so yeah
but I mean he might be here Friday he
might not we'll we'll see how that goes
he could recover I mean he recovered
before yeah he could recover so you know
we'll there's a chance like I said we're
just kind of I give him 50/50 it's very
touching go we're just seeing how it
goes and like I said if you weren't here
earlier um I actually got a fulltime job
which starts on Monday so yeah we're so
we're still going to do um the shows on
Monday evening Wednesday evening Friday
evening like we normally would but I
wouldn't um be able to do as many like I
wouldn't be able to do streams during
the week like in the afternoon for
example because I'd be at work so I'd
probably just do one stream a week like
on Sunday or something like that so you
know I'm still going to try and do that
yeah but you know what I mean yeah um
Jen Allen said thanks for a good show
fingers crossed for your dad yeah
hopefully it all works out we'll see how
it goes like I said we don't know what's
going on at this point so we're just
gonna I know more tomorrow yeah we're
just GNA kind of try and yeah play it by
ear is what we're doing but yeah thanks
everybody for dropping by this evening
thank you for your super chats they are
always appreciated and we will see you
guys again um or at least I will see you
again and maybe Tom will we'll see how
that goes um on Friday night for the
side track show so good night everybody